all right and we all love the last word
with Lord Candido
and a Baptist fresh by the campfire
Friday evening edition what's going on
we got special people to build it what's
happening we have very special people in
the building and it has been an
absolutely crazy week so we got an
awesome guest we got a lot of to talk
about so for those of you oh geez this
is gonna be a long pointed it-- so I'm
gonna send it right back sir let us know
let the whole world out there know who's
joining us tonight by the campfire you
already know so welcome to the last word
episode number 107 it's not the glorious
Friday way back in front of the campfire
for some more ludus unit discussion I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce a lord who is only one
of the most unique and passionate
content creators within our Destin
community but through his trials and
raid health dreams you are instantly
teleported to the booth the freethought
knocking beats and positive vibes
introducing the freestyle gamer plus
creator and host of the amaze twitch
channel the lord of pure vibes fellow
born warlock and by far one of the top
freestyle spreaders in the game live
from Richmond V a and kind enough to
make his debut at the campfire of the
last world mom a lord amazing the
building are you doing brother doing
well man I am it's been a mazing week
man very amazing yet busy but amazing
week it's been very very good for me too
it's amazing
amazing yeah it's been an amazing week
so yes I could actually say a lot of
these things are new to me very very I'm
not used to some of these things man and
I'm very very proud of it uh being
noticed I'm so proud of it
well I got I got again through yeah he's
been killing it but I gotta get into it
man because obviously you know I'm new
to your content he was one of the first
people that really put me on and he said
I want you to see something and for
anyone with the check was not familiar
with this brother like you a raid was
sent your way he just he has so much
confidence and what was about to happen
that I didn't know what's gonna have him
so he goes just sit there watch so he
goes down and you proceed to off the top
freestyle with II in in a live chat you
literally broke what you were doing
midstream
and just got like where does that come
from like that is amazing break it yeah
I could say where that comes from
it's literally all that my mind and um
my set is always a big key for me I
think I didn't focus on understanding
the mind meaning understanding self
which is me I didn't start focusing
notice in the mind itself maybe like
after high school after I graduated I
started writing a lot more and then as I
got to it man I was how you look I don't
need the write this stuff anymore
I think I'm so much better if my
freestyle I don't if I write it doesn't
sound it just sounds like you you're
writing something you're writing a story
and you spit it I just want to know it
off top of the mind how I really feel
you know what I mean so what I did was
when people come in they show me love
it's I I know I watch the channel and I
already have in my mind what type of
person that is you know I mean I know a
month city bonta's is uh rated me a
couple of times so what after I've seen
him it you know let me go ahead and stop
what I'm doing let me go ahead and kill
this hype it up but this entire check
and drop the raps and I just going man
the mind just it constantly flows when I
raps once I start the engine and the
engine starts to get hot that's when the
fires evil
so I sort of like the campfire you know
what I mean yeah absolutely brother yeah
stop you gay I was just kidding yeah the
first time was like somebody pointed me
to your chat and I was having a good
stream I was like man I want to send
this then they told me and I was like
sweet so he sitting over a check I was
like say hey and you literally as he
said stop dead Street first time I'd
ever done it's not dead stream and just
went and I'm just sitting there just
like Dave watching my computer and just
like sitting there going then your
mission me and got destiny in there and
I was like dude uh sure
especially me I'm just like in awe
because I like the talent there is
something I'm just completely I wouldn't
be coming out of my mouth so I'm just
like yeah or respect and that it was
amazing
social media is amazing from social
media man so uh hearing that go out man
started to go over to see what was going
on what was about I was like yeah you
know me it feels good when I have the
time as well watch people I usually go
watch me having a busy schedule or being
a delivery travel it's sort of hard so
hey hey bro so I guess my question for
you is I you know obviously we we all
got a passion for this game we just they
do we have this so much this thing of
ours at the campfire you know in some
way just break it down for the people
like you know why destiny why is it so
important to you and of course I gotta
ask you the question cuz me more like
bro so I got asking that question why
the walleye class as well but let's talk
for the beginning with destiny all right
why destiny
I love destiny I played it ever since
beta and I was introduced to destiny
from somebody at UPS when I was doing
loading back in a day me I didn't really
pay too much attention to video games
believe it or not um I had no time on my
hands I was working two jobs
China you know pay bills take care ro
you know stuff like that um-hmm he
introduced me to it
no matter if I could give me a made
uncle let me try it and I I wouldn't try
it I was like man I want it in there
with there were three classes to pick
from and I tried on three and I was just
like man I don't like first one I tried
was hunter and because of my mind I'm
thinking ninjas dead I'm like okay
and I um I don't like this I don't like
this class I wanted a Titan next I was
like ah man yeah you feel like somebody
from halo and I dropped them off and
then good luck but yeah I'm thinking of
this Dragonball Z I'm thinking magic
powers I'm thinking about level up some
more I am about to be the floating God
going spirit bombs at the floor and in
wall locking blinking all of these other
things that's when I was like oh my god
this is me this is me this is character
and as I you know when destiny came out
I only played with my friends which were
my RL friends I didn't accept more more
out into the open yeah um to the public
to the public and helping them I knew
nothing about LMG until after my friend
sort of gave up on destiny I didn't um I
kept going after I beat that first raid
something just like started me like I'm
like yeah and what Brad what my dad is
what was what was your first water glass
what's my first raid and my first exotic
was the ice breaker my good eye I know
we all had this intention reserved when
he first served a Gjallarhorn the first
day he appeared in and I ignored it
because I'm like it isn't known about
doesn't it that partly I need an exotic
rocky floor need it well I need better
guns you know I mean I want something
better I need no rocket see this rocket
all over the raid and being shot on my
Gjallarhorn I said what is that
at first I'm lost I'm like I don't even
know what a Cal her it is what is that
Gally
he said yes her sword the first week I
was like no I started I wasn't expecting
to get something like that I didn't even
think I wanted anything like that but
I'm yeah I went into those raids and um
after they left I started going on lfg
and man all right I start coming in I
start falling in love with I love G coz
back then
believe it or not ladies and gentlemen L
of G wasn't as toxic as it is now uh she
was much more efficient you met a lot of
cool people there there were a little
bit of people on a negative side that
no this is for quiet not get it um I
used to go on people's teams and I used
to hype them up motivate because then
every team I went into it sounds like
they had been here for hours
you know I mean believe it or not man I
just I wish has improved I go on
people's parties and then be like what's
wrong man what is the motivation
everybody good let's get this is like
whoa this guy who are you I'm the guys
going to help you beat this entire right
man let's do it
what's the problem with me tell me
issues and stuff like that and man I
start going through raids um I think
I've did the ball of glass helpful I did
I had a count of a thousand rate
completions in the bottle alone I really
I really went deep into destiny destiny
really uh really reeled me in um I just
wanted to meet people man um and uh
somebody recommended that uh one of the
LMG people would say man you should
stream the way you bowling these people
man this is something I would definitely
watch you just come in and you helped us
out I didn't think we won't beat it but
your motivation got us through it and I
felt so proud man um it was an amazing
moment man and ever since then I've just
been Iseman I just been in Destiny's
just been the game I I don't really care
about what other people thought of it
destiny brought me in I met a lot of
people because of it I don't know
another of a judge dust me for garlis if
it dies or it it stays you know what I
mean so that's what's up and I'm
tremendous story and thinking obviously
yeah like you don't say the passion
comes through what you do the energy
comes through right what you do you know
I'm saying and then obviously you're
doing like the trials helped yeah so
trials it's like how did you now form
the channel at the direction of the
channel and the question I got asked
also we're gonna have to talk about
these beats because I got these beats
man
you know from listening a channel is
like me going in my car and throwing on
Sirius XM radio and this is your station
and his mic is super late like the way
do but could take a break that bring
never right so the the channel itself
alone um wasn't the home of as before
believe it I just started getting
serious and so streaming until after I
got the laptop this laptop started
everything take notes - everyone I
started on Xbox I didn't have a camera I
didn't have help all I did was go on LMG
promote myself to people say hey I
didn't even have to see her and say hey
I'm streaming that's usually a bad call
and I was talking about a lot of other
stream was back in the day so I never
knew um I go into I love jeez and they
say I talk to somebody - I know you're
streaming oh yeah let me watch that
started growth so I start going from
five to maybe seven I started with two
and that was just me in my boy that was
it to me that one person was the best
person other it felt real man um knowing
that um then you started from the bottom
end and I I start working my way up
believing after I start going LMG raised
and I started hitting 500 completions I
start going from three to ten and then
it just sort of I got lucky by one big
host and I didn't even have a camera I
was on a xbox and someone a MIMO state
and I didn't rap rap wasn't my
entertainment theme back then none of
these things will they didn't come in
rap didn't come in until Oryx released
mmm and the thing about that was I was
still on xbox know that was still
talking about this I was still on Xbox
when I was doing this um we were under
we were doing Oryx and my best friend
could not make it through the puzzle and
my whole entire thing was if you cannot
make it through this puzzle I'm
obviously just gonna freestyle a story
about why you can't jump
believe it or not that one story turned
into a whole entire development of
coming up because I was restyling and I
got that big host while I was
freestyling on a hedgehog so why was
going on I'm freestyling bomb on my best
friend can't make jumps and I'm gonna be
rapping for five minutes cuz that's how
long it's gonna take you to make it over
here and uh we was a minute strong I'm
laughing I got the chat laughs and the
parties laughing she's laughs and while
she's trying to jump as we got through
that man quote Oryx came out then the
new raid Siva came out in next when I
had this mindset that alright I'm in
streaming this long it's time to take it
to another level people want the camera
um I went and got a blue Yeti I had a
blue Yeti that was my dog all these
recomendation Chet I don't have mine
right here yeah yeah the old logic
camera before the Logitech Brio it was a
regular logitech camera no green screen
my father's I was in my father's home
streaming on his beautiful Bibles he
just had the best internet was best
place for me to do it salute the files
with the file yeah yes yes I had a
old-school rocking chair and I was
streaming on it that was my first time
on a laptop for a while didn't know how
to OBS and none of that stuff worked at
first and sort of started sort of
learning it and from there on in man it
started to progress then destiny too
came out um before destiny - I didn't
play trials too much and destiny one
believe it or not I played more raids in
d1 before I started focusing trials in
d2 Charles r9 was a start I started
learning from a guy that I met in d1 who
taught me the ways of shooting um I felt
like he said if you can shoot in raids
and you can shoot
VP and now was that my said I stuck with
um his big thing was map awareness
knowing of radar nor where they know
where they're gonna play and I was a big
shotgun eight back in a day so blinking
with the warlock was just bad off even
if the hunters wanted to blink and try
to mess with the warlocks it just wasn't
done we taught you guys how to blink
chased down trials and I was good at it
for a little bit and then sort of died
out cuz more people were asking for
raids in chat so I was doing a lot of
raids
Sivir raids crota raids Oryx was the
main one that people needed which was
the best one for me because that was the
challenge a lot of people could not do
and some people still can't do believe
it or not D 2 came out man and then I
started vibing a laptop was still a
thing I was still using the same camera
and then I guess when season 203 hit I
started developing I started getting
ideas and I started looking at stuff and
Amazon's dangerous all those things I
wanted to do all of these things to get
these things done and I'm like well [ __ ]
yeah I need a green screen man I want a
green screen I need to get that I want
to be very very professional I want to
give you guys the quality that you
deserve and that's what I did um when I
got the green screen Juna got the
logitech Brio camera and my best friend
recommended that to me my wife went and
got me two lights I added four or five
extra lights you're like you're glowing
literally yeah uh I got the clone in
that's when it was time to start
grinding started started time it was
time to start making a disc or pop back
then I'm like who uses discord I'm d1
only no disc what am I gonna use I got
my xbox party man upon if I wish I knew
more about discord like I did back in
the day I'll be using just go away
earlier banana
Gordon went from 20 people to 720 people
I've um I progressed networking is a
very very strong thing I tell a lot of
people that networking is key staying up
with people Norma was out it was going
down Twitter
don't use Instagram too much but Twitter
and discord do a lot of talking and I
think that's how I got myself to be
noticed a lot more people were telling
other people about the channel cuz back
then my channel used to be called the
hype circle and the hype circle was
something that uh that I developed and
we used to use the the main Keys hashtag
HC so we dropped out in the hashtag age
scene I met an amazing designer that
wanted to make something copyrighted for
me called uhm which stands by amazed
well you can rock the uhm with shirts to
become assumes she wanted me to have
that mindset she was like no no you need
something that's gonna stand out what
people can rock this in the malls at
school go and I was like hmm how about
uhm it's just like I like that that
sounds so good it talks uhm that's based
around you and it's copy written it's
you age so amazed your logo that's all
me you want this all to revolve around
you
not your community home vibe because you
want this stuff evolve around you you
and I said okay and I said okay I'm cool
with that so we took that uhm we made it
to something serious and homer vibes was
a strong thing I must go I like to vibe
man that's always been my key and
passion since I started streaming was to
meet other people as I told you in the
beginning this story was to meet new
people fire with them and make people
feel good I never knew that the home of
vibes took it to the next level I took
people away from stress oh I took people
away from bad days or they having a bad
day they coming to home fabs listen to
the amazing and relaxed and type of
music because the music was made with
people not only just for people to be
entertained
I wanted that mindset what people can
watch me game and my people will work
and can put it on audio mode and have
music to listen to why they're working
I've always a big big key for me because
that's how I made it through work is
listening to music and I wanted to make
sure that people
watch my channel can listen to music
while they work while they're at the gym
and I had that feedback from a lot of
people a maze I was added Jim and I had
you up the music was amazing
no um Max and I put the I started
talking to djs djs became a thing and
you're the DJ say I like what you do DJ
start making my DJ vibes for me saying
oh my god all feels like the radio
station is like it's an actual radio
station on which you know max the the
deal with that was I wanted to track so
much attention
I wanted the traction I wanted it from
everywhere I wanted everyone to come
watch I'm still Mike mindset and goal is
to help other people and my see the
thing of is I want people to relax have
a good time but I also want to help
people who want to become bigger
streamers grow and that's what I made
the discord for not only just for you to
come in and vibe and hang out and chill
promote yourself get to know people in
the discord and then they'll watch you
and as they watch you more people will
watch you you get to know each other and
then you you build and you grow and then
you take that upon yourselves to what
you do and how you feel about what you
want to do as on your next step me I've
got a lot of goals in my head then
trials me too
Game of Thrones I was focused trials not
9 we like 9 die talked about 9 yeah we
we came in and try one sock was there
anything came into the deal I was
watching my boy play trials Bow Wow and
I was like man I want to be over to do
both I want to be able to do raids and
I'm gonna be able to do truck house you
need but most most don't do that that is
a very unique skill it's usually two
camps almost right evu silent pvp sign
right and usually a streamer kind of
fits in that pocket but when I saw that
you're doing both I was like wow that is
really unique and let's be real like
helping you
you're literally helping people in the
two hardest
pinnacle endgame activities in density
this is not like hey I'm gonna help you
get through that then strike today or a
knife or like this is literally you know
the hardest way communication all that
stuff and then trials you know we
Noah stirs the sweatiest of the slack it
is and that's the thing about positivity
in what I've been trying to push see the
thing about me when it comes to PvP is
I'm not gonna be the toxic guy I'm the
guy that wants to be the positives and
get rid of all those toxic kids that sit
there and bag somebody's amazing and
great casual players I'm the guy that
wants to go in and give out the
positivity and try my hardest to knock
these games out we took so many people
flawless and I know people can vouch
I've took so many people flawless no
charge we don't charge in the homework
laughs you just buy so you come on in
and I take you through we not get off
you have fun people know want to know
the weapons you're using hey this is
what I'm using if I have a weapon and I
can use I'm just going to use it I
turned good
I dropped the shotgun and then I started
being this amazing sniper sniping was my
most amazing ki head level neck level
knowing the placement Norman if I'm
gonna slide I'm aggressive sniper not a
campy one so I like the move and I like
the sniper I like transversal steps on
my bad boys oh these ornaments I don't
care about anything goes in the game are
getting poppies I want that orange
ornament cause it don't even look good
it look like a different color yes and
play trials for a long period of time at
that point man starting knowing
strategies try to work on still working
on strategies for other people when they
play I like to go ahead and be the guy
not the clutch but to make calls to make
people feel good when they play even if
you don't still like you're doing good
you got to be able to smell and play you
got to be ready to play you got to be
ready to go I can roll camping is also a
good thing a lot of people do but I want
me man if I can take the camper out so
can you
I always tell people just shoot your
good
don't be nervous and don't worry about a
stat no more money lows without looking
at people's elos stop looking up there
then we'll stop worried about what
flawless MLM they got cuz I don't care
that's true at the end of the day they
can be set down you know I mean I'm not
worried about any of them if they could
be shut down I'm gonna shut them down
yo I got a shout out to Bob whale or
dedicated chat aisle or salut you're a
bill he said he want to get down with
the hobo Vile's because he would've get
to the lighthouse I could guarantee you
I can get you to the lighthouse it's
also how it works I literally do
everything man I do everyone up shout
the Attic for sure that you typically
play with or you take it it's a couple I
started growing and started meeting
these most amazing as what people call
it sweat players now the growth the
numbers started meeting people say made
sure I had people message me say you're
a nice individual and we don't find so
many nice people who plate you know
trials like you know a good person your
positive vibe and your sniping heads off
like no tomorrow I want to help you I
had people I have melons that comes in
and helps he's a high end like top
player um I have cockroaches Concord is
is that that tight net speedy Titan I
have a loyal loyal as a hunter and he
rocks out with me those are the three
people I actually play with I like to
keep my my my sweat areas small because
I don't want anybody to feel like I'm
leaving them out or this that because
that's not where you go the more you
gotta clean up afterwards but be much
breeze I'm not I'm not trying to big I
built a big bridge I just think if you
want to play let's play you know I mean
if you don't want to play totally fine
I'm not looking for it but if you want
to play let's play
that's what so that's usually what it is
my circle is pretty small when it comes
to just what community I try not to get
them is because I don't know how the
operations work with other a lot of
sweaty players because they really do
play they come to play you know they
don't come to to joke around when they
see me bring somebody in they respect it
and what I respect from from these
sweats is they respect who are bringing
in and they know the vibes very strong
how positive it is that right man either
keep it clean it's amazing me a man's
positive man I gotta make sure you know
respect him um and I think a lot of
people actually respect me in a
situation when it comes to that poor
viewers in man
I usually that the cards get done and if
they don't get done we'll try to get you
in the next time usually it can get
really really sweaty well I have to jump
in and do it for you well more than
likely we we not get out no no no no
questions asked we try to get through it
man I play it on console not on PC
ladies and gentlemen because as you know
PC people out there doing Goku's
floating around like Kakarot and and I
don't need nobody throwing big manga
attacks on me while I'm trying to get
somebody flawless and I'm looking and we
just started to imagine there's a noble
bomb coming all the way from the other
side of the map and Wow we don't know
how that got there so I'm gonna be away
from the PC just a little bit today you
know get the anti cheat wear it and
everything right for right now we stick
the console try to get you guys flawless
crawl savers definitely a way to go if
you can't get on there Mazal hop on it
for you no charge we don't charge
anything I don't like to charge anybody
anything I just love it when people
watch entertainment is key for me and
that's using my fame and my main focus
game is a strong platform I'm using it
I'm freestyling we're giving out the
love that's just what I do man so that's
why I do raids I'd raised a lot the week
and didn't do trials on a week envelope
brothers a little brush tremendous
history Wow
like super dope so glad I came across
your content man what you talk for days
like what for me I like this dude please
hook this brother up cuz he is never
gonna get the information he looks at
all this hey hold on turn to the side we
got like competitive little cup here man
I know we got it we got what a viable we
got a lot going all right he was was
popping man oh my in the world I don't
know if you guys were awake on Tuesday
but man there was a lot going on on
Tuesday so we had probably speaking of
vibes some of these like zest vibes from
Bungie that I've ever had and
day we've got an interesting couple of
days as well but I want to start out
with just kind of the reveal of
everything that we got the hour-long
stream the trailers that we got the
information there's a lot to break down
and as I said strap in guys we have a
lot of information to cover so if you
got to grab a bite grab a drink of water
yeah we will be here for a minute so we
got we got a lot to cover but when it
started first I just want to talk about
how the stream started and just the way
that stream started with just the
silence the countdown and everything and
I just kind of wanted to get you guys
thoughts about that how they handled it
and just if you guys you know if you had
expected that knew it was come in or you
know just what you guys thought when it
actually happened when you were watching
um you know I my thoughts on him and I
teared man um as strong for me if
everybody was watching um when I was
doing it I um I had literally turned the
music off and I had everybody I my chat
about it like just complete silence
don't speak don't type just a sound
my head down I have my head down and I
um I stay quiet stay silent and I teared
and net and that uh that entire tired uh
thing I was very proud of what budget
did that something to me um ever really
touch man and I um I it was it was
definitely unexpected let me tell you I
wasn't expecting it uh for us to be you
know showing so much love of Floyd uh
the the love that they date they put out
for that I was was very very amazing I
respect what they did for that night
even posted on Twitter show some love
think the Cosmo for Cosmo is a good guy
that was much needed
um just show bungee you know how much
they care but for the whole entire you
deal what's going on right now cuz a lot
of craziness man but I absolutely
absolutely yeah I mean um kind of echo
your short survey thoughts of means cuz
like for me you know I'm and he knows
this about me I'm not a a big you know
let's shout to anybody wanna get down
with the movement and weep up preaching
positivity but I'm not really the
biggest like corporate hashtag kind of
guy I'm more of a a judge a person by
the actions kind of thing but that was
so cool because we knew the significance
and it to me they got it you know I mean
and that's that's what I really
appreciate it and that's that man's life
you know that means so right
salute to everybody trucks go mile make
it short photo yeah man that that was
super powerful and great touch what you
dingy oh I mean I was doing the same
thing I was Co stream it and I just like
shut it down turned off my camera and I
was just like I let it go and honestly
one of the coolest things I saw is there
was a lot of people that are Co
streaming it at the time and I was like
while that was going on I literally just
checked twitch and the the destiny
commute like the destiny whole community
was just that entire thing covering that
whole page like everybody was streaming
at the same time and I was just I mean
there was already 180,000 or however
many people watching bunchy but every
other content creator was doing it
silent and just just an entire plate so
that paid to that and I thought that was
that was really cool I thought that was
all they absolutely did to me that's
what I considered getting it and
understanding and in just a respect
level of what's going on having your
pulse on the climate of what's happened
in the world and I salute the bungee for
that I was really a fantastic job right
look you got the CEO out there like in
the place you guys have seen him on
Twitter to be part there that's just
standard with the rest and I was just
yeah just mad respect for everything but
that's not easy man you're doing that
stuff I tell people man if you want to
do that stuff man be safe yeah taking a
chance every time you go out there and I
appreciate every minute of what
everyone's doing coming together like
this so it's really good yeah absolutely
I would start see I had to start on that
and I was like okay they already knocked
out of the park they don't need to do
anything else but then they of course
blew the doors off of everything we had
the six foot one person lay between the
two stools to know how far apart they
were I heard that was awesome because
they measured that floor to see and you
had Luke and Mark talkin and honestly
that was really cool because for one you
actually had them like dude I haven't
seen you since
right now you're months ends like that
because they started before everybody
they shut down Seattle way before
everybody else started I hate being
stuck at home for awhile so they haven't
seen each other for months and they're
like hey we usually hang outside of work
and everything so they're just chatting
they're almost like kind of vibe and
getting a little bit back into it and
everything and then they just start
laying it on us and they started with
the trailers and we didn't even get to
Season eleven and I was like my mind
already exploded we have you got to
season arrivals which we got a whole
bunch of cool stuff in but the first
thing we got is that kind of I'm trying
to remember all the order but I'm going
through kind of the website so I get
this stuff how to order
forgive me I'm good you could but we got
the beyond light trailer and we got the
trailer for where we're going because we
had seen on Twitter we had like drifter
showing up okay cool
coming out of his little ship flying to
Europa then we had eros trudging across
the snow the red energy in the ground
and then there's all these little like
rumors of like who's like the three
who's the third one and then everybody
and then you got the little Tex
from an abrasive a there's this Lake
stranger thing that happens and stuff
mmm and sure enough twice the stranger
from deep one vanilla six years later
makes makin the comeback and she came as
though she kid did she can drive a
sparrow like nobody's gotta teach me
cuz i undefeated in Sparrow racing like
100% I agree ugly so yeah we get to see
that and then we see them kind of meet
up and like stare each other down for a
second she has her little floaty fish
that's next to her yes the non-ghosts
little lake thing that everybody now
wants and then you turn and see there's
a pyramid ship and we get a bit of a
breakdown on beyond light so that was
just a trailer so when you guys watch
that trailer like again we're just going
chronologically as best as I can
remember how this went beyond light
trailer would you guys pull from that
what you see would you like thoughts on
that one
oh yeah maze well yet I tell you this I
mind blown
I'm just mind-blowing the pyramids I
midnight and know about these pyramids
since that's anyone when I saw it in
their little pitches as we were waiting
for downloading and updates and you see
the little pair of Medicine in the
Bangla what are those things those
things like missions but man I think it
was real with me man when I saw the when
I saw Eris the XO mmm and The Drifter
all coming together in this situation
and the drip that just looked like he
playing no games
explain like Oh to look like a plane
okay if you look like I don't know I
don't know who that is
I know err no know who you is who you
the pyramids coming into the deal man
taking over that's crazy they are
killing this story right now I'm I'm
psyched how did I that how they are
bringing in so much sneaky stuff and
then voting some of the old stuff I
think that's amazing bring him back some
d1 that Cosmo drone Lord I can't wait to
see what that looks like or destiny to
now just on destiny to on PC at night so
ANSYS it's so much to take in water
glass the deep stone crypt is sold
you saw just that first beyond blight
trail you got to see them staring ship
and they start breaking down who we're
fighting what's going on what you I'm
gonna get to the subclassed in a second
but I want like just the trailer first
like when you got the confirmation that
it was the stranger were you like when
did you know in the trailer cuz like
they had like the silhouette with the
gun in that like fire dark and I was
like oh and then it showed the gun it
was like darkness so that was once I
once you see the gun it just felt good
because for me you know being a destiny
fan one of the criticisms is always bad
oh it's cool but the story's not great
and then you know I'm saying it or
whatever like you always get the
narrative attack yeah and for destiny
hardcore fans you don't understand that
the stranger has so much significance
right this is a character we have not
seen and so long and no questions where
has the stranger been we got to shout
the bike if we got a little bit of
clarity you know what is it I believe
the warmind dlc and then you know the
Foresti you know the Elsi Bray and all
that stuff maybe it was just like what
is going on there's so much things that
transpired since so to see how pull up
you know it just is a very emotional
thing so for me like we talked about
last last word this is like avenge his
endgame to me we're getting the major
players to do might not all have the
same motivations or like you you have
what you have like the weirdest three
musketeers this is a really odd
situation cuz you don't drift this for
self I don't know if for himself oh yeah
I did heiress you know that's that's
that's people but she don't you know
there's always a little mystery where is
with the how much is she affected be you
know saying there's a little questions
with her she's always helped us he's
always been like little questions and
stuff like that and then now we got to
see like what was the strangest purpose
what have they what's she been doing all
along so to me it was man it was really
cool
I love the
an easiness of the seed that's what hit
home like like amazing when you see the
drip the light you're reaching for any
situation I don't know what you thought
thanks but I'll be that for me it was it
was really really just look cool hey
thank God so mind-blowing thinking about
it right now is still mind-blowing man
yeah like I've watched that trailer
multiple times and you just see like
she's gonna her like uh the reach for
the gun uh but then you see like the
stranger just right up and like hockey
snotty materializer space just like and
just like smooth just keep walking sexy
walk yes yeah yeah Ito Nick gave her age
she killed me Gabriel walk that was in
d1 ladies and gentlemen explain now it
could be if I'm wrong here I'll get back
to you um did she say like did she
construct this meeting I got the vibe
like she was like there's a reason why
you guys are here or something like that
it seemed like that like I gotta go
again can't watch at the middle of the
stream so I don't go back to be sure but
it's like this is what I wanted to show
you or something like that is what she
said something like that like yeah he's
wanted cut out right there I just want
to see what it is like what is it don't
play me like those
that's the background we got in the
stream it's like this is the pyramid
ship that's active them on Europa so
brand new destination ice-covered planet
or ice cover moon sorry I'm not playing
I've got to get it right and we should
run them right now we'll say Lake thanks
to the pyramid ship light bright wall
and all the stuff that's been going on
currently now have a minor in astronomy
working on patreon tell us everything
about these planets their closeness of
the almighty I learn all type of things
about spices got brains man let me tell
you okay so we have ice-covered moon
next to Jupiter obviously Jupiter crazy
giant planet so skybox is gonna be
amazing on this thing I can't wait to
see that but we're sitting here and you
see them look out on another part
pyramid ship sitting on this icy covered
moon and the Luke and Mark start
breaking down kind of the story of
what's going on a little bit and they're
talking about the fallen captain that's
kind of basically out for a revenge
story against the traveler because the
traveler came you know showed them the
light stripped it away and they
patiently wouldn't ever collapse as well
this is one of the final houses and
they've kind of banded under Aramis now
shout-out to my stupid self before I
actually read the page of Beyond light
because at first I was literally making
notes about the video and it's just
typing in document I was like Aramis so
it's like F so I type er a mus or
whatever is that cool and then I was
like wait a minute
Aramis isn't that one of the three
musketeers then I looked and you got
Porthos Athos Porthos and Aramis now it
said in a different way but I was like
blah so I wonder if that was it so
literally in my video about like the
future of destiny I say it and
somebody's like this is different I went
to go look at beyond light and they
spell it differently I was like I know
one she likes to say pull names like
eros is a centaur like far past Neptune
there's literally like a celestial
object called eros and it was like
really guys so they'll do that type of
stuff so I thought that's what was it
but then they changed the name on me so
of course I had to eat my own words but
either way we have the Fallen has like
the main and as I'd never expected this
the Fallen is kind of a main enemy race
that we're gonna be fighting in the fall
and big giant bomb drop stasis
yeah so we have a new new set of
subclasses which look freakin awesome
with like ice picks and staffs I can't
figure out what the Titan giant blocky
fists are we look like we're weird but
the fact that is actually a new
elemental class on weapons we're gonna
have a stasis auto rifle and rocket
launcher and energy weapons so that's
like yes stasis like we got the Fallen
once you guys get your thoughts on that
but like stasis that was the big the
game changer I mean it's ice covered so
it makes some sense for like one
question first for you guys what do you
think it's gonna be represented by color
wise because we already have blue and it
seems like whitish like is it whiten hey
I think I'll be like an icy dark you
know what I mean like a dark icy color
because it seems like in my sense it's
not an actual new subclass it's a add-on
to the sunglasses that Oh pops yeah yeah
I mean so I'm looking at it like I'm a
warlock you bout to give me this kind of
power in my mind what we about to do now
being the only showed city but she was
being a little stingy because they were
show the Warlock we saw was the hunter a
little warlock with its like ice staff
which looks kind of awesome by the way
and looks pretty excited you know I mean
for what these classes want to do it's
new its new
so these things are game changes I
wanted to know I want to get involved
with the darkness stuff and we I get
into the dark to get what we need to be
I've been dying for this moment I just
can't wait is six years in the making
and we still got another three months
for all this stuff
exactly content man it's right here
really cool Val yeah it was definitely
you know welcome we we know September is
generally the meaty stuff September 8
not only do they introduce you know
generally a raid and very beefy story
content well the thing is they always
add mechanic
destiny you know you know finishers it
that's why I love September so much but
it's it's literally like a reimagining
of heavy as grad of a grind
i'm mateus grind you know the deal I
mean I remember when we first got you
know you know stormcaller and sunbreaker
oh that's a learning it was good the
store trains and it's just the weather
the creation of the weather all yes we
about to learn I wish they added I wish
they added the weather effects in some
of these maps I think that would be
amazing the fact that they added storage
in weather jokes and maybe little
weather weather slider I would love that
it's raining out here with shooting ads
it wasn't raining last time now it's
sunny out is it not I mean make people
feel more on these maps okay if it was
raining out there there's a new message
of new mission with the rain out there's
so many things they could do man so I
mean for me it's just like and the cool
thing at least what I got from it y'all
was that like to meet it going back to
d1 vibes with the customization of this
tree so cuz remember the complaints with
d2 has been kind of like we're stuck in
these boxes and I believe Luke kind of
made a point where it's not we're gonna
have that I'm gonna be honest
it felt like Luke listen to the outrider
streak I cannot be petty for a second
I felt I ride this kind of took a shot
at destiny with some of the things they
were saying at they live stream you know
say and it also density has
customizations of the UI all of a sudden
destiny is like yo we got a skill tree
down with this stasis thing and and we
could pick where we want to go with it I
don't know baby I'm looking words I just
felt the petty bag was out on that one
part right there but honestly I do like
the fact that um you know it's really
let's go to Larry oh what's up man dido
when we gonna get the flawless run we
gonna get that pop it was several but um
yeah I really like the fact that we're
going back to customization we're not
locked in and I'm
dying to see like I know what I may say
it feels like a a dull one it feels like
this this is gonna be an add-on we're
gonna integrate stuff but II I'm curious
about you do you think there's leg solar
arc and void and they're like the stasis
is like within those correct it's
basically like a solar arc void separate
Dyson sitting over here stasis is truly
its own subclass like new melees new
grenades new sunglasses for stasis for
each of our characters that's higher
that was it's it's the stasis is
attacking each class maybe as a seasons
progress so maybe we might get stasis on
maybe the solar class and then maybe on
the next season in might hit the art
class just to keep that stasis effect
going as we get more deeper in tune with
the darkness you know I mean cuz we're
still learning we still don't know
nothing about this darkness what's just
learning so Aries is probably let us get
in the water cuz we got to now we got
here we gotta get in the water
we gotta yeah it's gonna be interested
to see how it how it plays out cuz
there's still we still got a lot of
questions right early integration they
still have more to show us but it was
just I think overall is just cool what
he Swinney said the words we're getting
like a new you know subclass or whatever
it is you know the terminology they use
it and I like shot yeah I want to know
how much we're gonna get a chance to mix
and match it's a fun time that type of
game-changing stuff it really excites me
in September yeah I'm excited about that
too I think that's very very interesting
that they're doing all that man yes sir
yes sir
when I was so much knowledge dropped in
there ah yeah I do want to read this one
part it just says we love darkness from
this beyond light web page says real
darkness guardians will wield this new
elemental power alongside arks dollar
and void again I so is like is that so
again this is where I'm asking like is
it separate or is it like it sounds like
you'd stack all for next to each other
like it's one of your four options but
again is there am i reading that wrong I
don't know like the I kind of got amazed
vibes when I don't know what he was
really kind of felt I don't know if I
gotta watch it yeah I thought
remember him saying kind of like
integrated but I was just so high maybe
I miss I don't know well either way I
just remember him saying the
customization part specifically I do
remember that boy I had no you know how
about I definitely don't for sure that
what this the class is it it's
definitely seems like I don't think he's
like what I'm seeing from what I was
watching it I'm very sure is mixed in
subclasses but maybe it might be a
separate but I'm pretty sure it was
integrated into another subclass I'm
just not sure which one it is
so like III don't I don't know what the
supp neither
I either way when they talk about lake
titans hunters and warlocks use stasis
in different ways from slowing down foes
to encasing and shattering enemies with
destructive might
it all sounds awesome minutes they play
the game that's like the biggest times
in this game that I've always enjoyed is
like when you we went you know we got
the new subclasses for a forsaken game
changer adding new trees new ways to
build new counters in PvP totally
different and just the more variation
especially when you got a PvP I'm sorry
it's got to be hard for them to balance
but it sure makes it fun for us menu bar
for us mmm so else we got he dropped a
lot in there man Luke was Luke spit bars
in there he was man Lord Jesus I keep on
thinking let's keep on talking Lukey boy
was too short but yeah he definitely
packed a lot of information in there so
we got information about Aramis and then
we got a little tease about a certain
place for a raid location then that's
been wandering about it
I haven't weighed knowing that one for
you oh wow I'm hyped about the deep
stone crib I mean I can't wait the
experience that man anytime is a new
rage or something like that and I've
been we need to know about the deep
stone crib with this is too long and too
long so long for the Bungie to actually
go dug deep down and dive down into some
of these things that we've been like
lost in the story to know about I'm
actually like happy about that that's
that's wrong willing deal man
what Jesus bring in some of these stores
that we thought died and they bring they
sneak up on you like that and waiting
character though I'm proud because they
kept everything on a hush we knew
nothing he wasn't expecting Allah
discount to be late now sent once all
the DS trailer reveals none of us was
expecting that know Jesus they catch out
with a great bang beautiful yeah and one
thing I keep here and everybody's like
deep stone crypt it's like are we
getting to getting it getting anything
back related decayed that's why
everybody wants a 1k look at me yeah you
know we can't I don't know if we can go
back eight seven but this would
definitely be the place I can't I can't
I don't want to deal with the what's his
name man I have all these these news is
I'm here about this guy I don't want to
I don't want him to know he said there
listen to some some ugly-looking Scully
looking eyeball tell him to go kill this
herb a queen and go say nothing like
that man bro is his system man he got a
rifle assist I thought he was a brother
we did we did we 91 like help assist ow
I know he didn't like us but bro in you
I mean it will be all I would say this
you know obviously shout to my hunters I
know they want they want they want to
hold me back they 1kv back we know deep
stolen credit for did Ace of Spades back
that quest that exactly that was really
that his will was one of the really well
done you know story pieces in d2 so you
know he mentioned deep stone crab he
mentioned some like horrible things
almost he alluded don't horrible things
dance old as we know I'm not the Lord
thing I'm shot the bike but I'm assuming
that's like where the XO's are created
or something yes yeah mmm so axles are
something that we haven't gotten really
deep law was starting to touch it now we
started to touch it with fell winter
with his story just recently you know
I'm saying we we now getting it you know
the strange your bag you know X those
are coming to this you know think so it
would be cool to get even if Kate
doesn't come back which I don't think he
is what to get history to get dial or to
get a callback right now to where he was
created and stuff like that
it this is a dolt thing I think it's
really cool that they're touching this
story I can't wait to see how they tell
me a shot a question I don't think that
it would be the stranger that's gonna be
in case but
I don't know what's going on with one of
the most confusing cat is the strangest
Ranger in the future like yeah yeah yeah
weird and where's she from yeah yeah
poor like what you been you says a pair
of nice we just shot down all my did you
miss all this yes he already thought
about that with the almighty crouched
after the last word happened this week
the almighty exploded and we didn't even
talk about it okay quick sidebar here
yeah we know it obviously was like
longer than everybody seems to think it
should have been but when that actually
went down do you guys like my reaction
video is probably stupid to go back and
watch because I'm like it exploded like
oh damn and that I'm like running to the
other side of the tower to see it crash
in the mountains and stuff like that but
I know the first like 86 minutes of the
stream could have been a little long but
about the last five my experience I
would just tell you right now I didn't
get to see I didn't get to go online and
watch it live what I would tell you my
story okay I took on took my lunch break
well that's only 30 minutes boss boss
kind of already knew about it cuz I
wasn't look up coming in to work but I
can gotta watch this almighty thing job
ahead of time so he knew what I was
talking about he's like you still said
no I'm still wait for to get shot down I
mean he was he was laughing he was like
what look when the thing is done then
get back to work I don't have much work
all that it do was pick ups but so also
my man is this thing really going drop I
was like like the 30 minute grace period
of mainly
look at my screen for a whole 86 minutes
because in my mind I'm like take my eyes
off of it you go really well miss no I
just like i I see sparkles I'm looking
now i alright what's Helen I don't think
it's all good yep Almighty was fabulous
and glittery so yeah I thought I thought
that was a shield the entire time all I
okay - heat guard the the the Rasputin's
shots Almighty fight back what's
happening you know I was thinking I was
gonna be a war but that's new that's new
and it's amazing look how many people
watched it oh my god
let the rectory was jumping for destiny
yeah - it was a bunch just like
Destiny's like hey guess what we're back
to number five exactly I just when I
watch the drop man I'm like she jumped
move I'm looking at streams I like I
should move right now that thing is
coming yeah we should get out of the way
but I just wish I was a part I wish I
was one man yeah it was it was listen
you know shadow we talked about or IOP
you know it's one of those things that
yes could it have been done a little
faster absolutely but it was truly cool
to see the tech because apparently I
believe was an office Noseworthy or Lord
oh my be large I think was large yeah
yes house in Lombok and he was like that
um there was you yeah utilizing new
technology to do this world event and
we've only seen stuff like this in like
fortnight and stuff like that so to see
destiny incorporate this technology when
they finally hit you felt the you know
the impact you felt that thing coming
through you felt the danger controller
was shaking the wind was swirling
you're like what is happening you know
I'm saying and I just think it's a
really cool beginning of things they can
set up for the future with similar type
events and let's be real like they they
stopped the internet like when you erase
you're at work like to me
Twitter was the event caused people is
like yell is to show started people had
joke
work at all like and then remember they
did kind of set us up like you'll be
there at so it's like everybody
everybody's like it's like going to a
show or concert and you did the study
show go start cut it out but it was it
was cool because everybody start talking
you know a man could win yet I felt like
that bring everybody together even
though it does happen at all I've seen a
lot of people say thank you bungee I got
to play well I got to meet a lot of my
old friends I haven't played in so long
and you know stuff like that's a strong
feeling it might have jumped yeah but
you had a lot of people you can catch up
well he's missing him forever kid so
much pictures of like everybody lined up
with the that was amazing I looked at it
when it dropped and it just like look
like a theater man like oh yeah think
about this think about how many people
in the tower like your width everyone's
like I can't take off I can't say I want
I watch everybody these photos they were
posted it was amazing destination it was
all dusty all over Twitter oh my oh my
and it was amazing man oh you see
Granick you get oh no it's just gonna
say then gotcha I'm probably saying that
wrong basically just said it's like if
the proof of concept like if they know
the tech is working picture the stuff
they're gonna do in the fall and the
next season what can you imagine just
like that scale and you're sitting on IO
but like what if like the pyramid ship
starts like turning and doing something
you're you're on a different pyramid
ship and it like or a planet and it
drives it like the stuff if they know it
works now like honestly can't wait to
see what they do it that yeah yeah the
potential for this tech because again
let's be real I told you I was
completely wrong I'm like they gonna
give us a cinema and that'd be it like
they're super cinema Almighty getting
shot down and that was it but for I'm
gonna do a live event really cool now
sets up future content and future live
events like yo you know those you know
you could you imagine what happened you
should have been there moments when this
no it's really cool
sandals weekend else we got okay anyway
back to where we were
since had a set-aside button since
that's moved for us all right so we got
B all Mike coming in the fall yes we got
Europa coming new destination brand new
destination been rumored forever by the
way the content artists like Cygnus for
yeah
we've got Aramis so we know the Fallen
race is gonna be involved you know we've
got like ice shields with stasis mmm
they're not even done they're like oh by
the way here's the next two years past
Leon light of content we got the witch
queen in 2021 we got a slight fall in
2022 and I was just like that happened
Green staple in my credit cards to the
wolf so when that happened I was just I
was kind of just in shock when I was
watching it on stream and stuff and I
got to get your guy's reactions first
cuz yeah two more years like confirmed
Sabbath oon and then lightballs the the
imagery for light falls really
interesting so one of you guys thoughts
on the fact that we know three years is
coming three years are you ready to lock
in yeah I think the Babs is just gonna
get stronger from here because I'm
thinking cuz the night not just for me
it's for anybody this is just for people
who stream destiny who thought it was
going to be dead and you're like what am
I gonna stream but this is not just only
for us ladies and gentlemen contact
creators this is for you this is a
chance destiny is going to be big
there's gonna be huge a lot of people
what are we coming back and I'm gonna
watch a lot of people so I just think
that's not only it is amazing just to be
enjoying the content and you play it
yourself it's gonna be a lot of help and
a lot of amazing things for a lot of
content creators so I just I think it's
gonna be fun I'm ready to meet a lot of
new people especially the old ones
that's coming back because of the D one
things are there bring it back in again
people been dying for the boarding
things so even more than e1 things and
you see the part of glass coming what
else do you think is coming Oh major
things I'm just oh so many things when
I'm high bottom and you have no idea I
just got I just feel no I just look at
it like this I'm ready to meet a lot of
new people so I'm reading all of it so
this is this is gonna be amazing man
yeah um EEE
all right let's just get to it because
um I didn't think he would ever answer
these questions and you know I know mu
but we're getting to them afterwards had
him and he got deeper but the initial
reveal when he's like look we're not
putting another number on this yeah like
just to get out in front of that shot at
the screen while screams and a chat with
us he had predicted this for some time
you know I mean me and you have gone
back and forth on whether or not now
initial reactions I'm like okay how is
this gonna work it does they got it
there but you know the way he broke it
down and here the game is just big you
know they they talked about constraints
of that they talked about file size
Norsworthy and all yeah yeah you know
and they said look you know what we're
gonna do is we're gonna kind of fold
some stuff we can bring some things back
here and there but we got it we can't
just keep expanding it at the way it is
and um it's an interesting approach
I look at it right now you're expanding
look at trials and Osiris and stuff like
there's the bugs that you're trying to
stop this time of stuff so they don't go
walking so many of these problems with
these these things eternal release I'm
proud of that I was clapping yeah I love
that
dad no absolutely absolutely so this
thing's gonna be around you know I was
gonna get into a couple of announcements
that he said if it's already jumping
ahead you know you know that we got the
no number we got the next-gen consoles
60 frames finally so consoles console
nations stand up welcome to 60 gray
literally this is why I went on be easy
to blame he's the one that got me on PC
this is the reasons you know I'm saying
because at the end of the day that
difference in fluidity now the questions
gonna be are we gonna get our fov you
don't say all that stuff but 60 frames
is huge
then we've got hints of arm you know
cross Deb Jenna we gotta hit some you
know the cross save how it's gonna work
initially you know it's gonna be
platform specific so Xbox guys gonna say
well actually these are huge
announcements and the reason why I don't
want to sugarcoat it is because one we
needed the confirmation for console guys
on that that's a huge thing that's who
cross play the consult for console guys
there was always this fear that when the
next-gen consoles come out in a
multiplayer game if that one group is 60
frames and the other group is 30 there
were rumors that yo they would not allow
it and take the higher end version down
to 30 for some competitive parity stuff
and people will like know if we have the
ability to do it we should do it so to
see them work with Playstation to see
them work with Xbox and then announce
that that initially year one they're
gonna be Xbox goggle stable exercise and
so on but surprisingly the next year
right they're shooting for it fall let
me explain how huge that is for the
destined commute this is a game about
playing with your friends we've got
cross save which is great but true cross
play gotta see how they integrate it was
stated got to see how they do
competitive with PC because you know
they got a mouse a keyboard but maybe
last year has dedicated servers for P if
you go cross play I feel like you think
Manning's getting on your man is backing
away from that dedicated Lupo had him in
the clutch man he was he's gonna squid
like we not doing dedicate I was
disappointed with that part but you
don't know at the end of day tremendous
announcement I will say I gotta say one
big I'm not trying to rain on a parade
he's only one concern shout the for city
in the chat okay I get it with keeping
destiny 2 and no 3 and no number but my
only concern is this engine cuz right in
the beginning you're one we gonna be
reopened
60 frames on consoles we good the game
still looks good but as the next-gen
goes on and these newer mmo's come out
and you running around with this you
know seven year old it's like i reaiiy
get it people telling me you're cog you
can update it you can do this stuff with
it I just need to see because at the end
of the day you know a lot of these
next-gen games are gonna try to compete
with destiny they're gonna be built on
next-gen Hardware off rip and we already
see coming some kind of the works of the
engine now we get a lot of bugs we get a
lot of air you know me so I just want to
see how they handle it because it's kind
of nice to get a new Lamborghini when it
come out yes
it's kind of nice we still run around
with this old jerk but I just want to
see I got faith and Bungie but they need
to prove to me that this this engine can
withstand the test of time throughout an
entire generation now that's what I'm
curious to see what you guys feel about
that
because that was the only thing in my
back of my mana I like the overall
direction of all the announcements but
that's the only thing that's kind of
needling me I got it they gotta prove it
too because I don't know how this this
engine can hold up again may as well let
you take it first man I bought the
engine on a the snip the one that we're
talking about right now yeah it's like
it's gonna be with us for about three
years
sounds like I'll be honest with you not
in money I mean I wasn't looking forward
three they gotta pick one no more
Angeles decimal ones engine was totally
fine and then you went to d2 people want
happy with it they try to start off
something different and it it went okay
well the engine is okay when we go back
to that d1 engine using you fill it d1
still it's you could do so many things
even though it's not it wasn't I think
of what it was what the biggest problem
was was PC but also they're released
destiny at a different date than
concentrate and stuff like that
so they had to focus on making sure that
those things were also already on PC as
a because the engine on pc yeah I think
about it it's 60 frames and there's one
way past you know most
wait wait guys now child again I don't I
don't obviously care for 301 just just
strongly just to be called destiny just
add names to it like like me you know I
mean like if you want just call the
destiny destiny on light I mean we don't
need a one two or three cuz this game at
the end of the day we are destiny just
call it destiny you know I mean I feel
like I'm I don't be looking for number
two or three we can see change that's
totally fine and they're doing it
they're doing it avoiding things that
they're helping people with their memory
but would how much they can store on a
for game because the game that games one
there's new ones gonna take up a lot of
space
oh yeah i'ma tell you but the engine
wise I'm pretty I'm pretty proud of what
they got going on man I'm like I like
sometimes it's a bad direction and we
gotta be the was experiencing
I think they've found where they are
right now I've got used to this - what's
going on with their patterns and the
guns I like the way everything feels the
only thing I think they need to work on
is a little bit is they just got them
they gotta work on that PvP side their
PvP side is really really good but I
think they lost so many people with the
PvP sides they don't have enough people
to help fix things on the PvP side
because PvP is always constantly
complaining PvE sides is 100 K but the
PvP side man no matter what you do or
what you fix they are going to find a
problem
they already you know I mean try to
adjust to some of the things they tried
you just I look at it like this man you
got to give them something they're their
own company now they're not what anybody
else
the we had that help back there and he
had people with them they don't have
that anymore so PvP is going to be a
little bit of a struggle you know I made
this gun broken this gun broken anytime
they fix a gun I know you guys have
found another gun that's broken so it
doesn't even matter you know they like
it just got to give it time in so I
thinking when this ball comes
I think PvP is want to be on point I
think they're gonna hit it right on the
nail on this one man because they bring
it back so many old things like that
the old pvp maps ah man just seeing it
on this new engine I'm just I want to
see the new stuff the new
Destinee one stuff on this new issue so
i'm hype about that that i want to see
what the vault of glass feels like i
want to see what everything feels like
on on to engine i want to i'm going into
d1 i'm going to the cosmodrome i am
going to these places i want to see what
sally what all this stuff feel like and
I know y'all want to do the same thing
oh it takes you way back man I'm well
that's how I feel I'm ready for this
I'm excited ready I'm confident he's
confident I'm very cool man I've always
been confident in Bungie man I don't
never doubt a man just takes time for
them guys oh no doubt e where you at man
engine I mean I've we've probably been
on similar like wavelength for a long
time on this was just trying to see
because of you see what the new tech can
do they talk about its I mean and that's
kind of a question of like we've always
talked about a d3 which if it does
happen it's at least three years away if
they ever get to that point it's
literally the way the game is built it's
the way the levels are milled it's the
way the worlds are built and it's these
little like you know canyons of loading
screens and all that type of stuff
that's the piece and again maybe they're
like hey give it three years we're doing
this now consoles have a bigger
generation they don't want to launch a
brand new game built only for these next
gens or you know very small player base
they want that you know get that first
40 50 million people on these new
next-gen consoles and then you have a
bigger place to sell to but again also
in our side we're like okay so we're
still gonna be like bloat in this
generation still feeling like it's held
back a little bit so it's tough but it's
like for a new new in at some point I
feel like that has to happen because I'm
scared of it man that's the only thing
I'm just scared of these new engines
because this d2 is like did you see I'm
bill five did you see how that new tech
bra you're gonna see those lumens and I
love it which is I was out there but
think about it every time we get
graphics you can get graphics and you
can get the most amazing image for a
case down but the gameplays gotta it's
got to combine and you know I've never
seen I've never seen people do two at
once any company I've never seen if it's
the gameplay that has the
thing then the graphics a little off if
it's more graphical then the gameplay is
a little so you should have confidence
with the new tech they will give us some
fire I don't wanna I don't wanna do one
engine in thought that D one engine was
gonna be in d2 how many of us thought
that when we seen it I played a d1 and
you know the feel of the game playing d1
right we didn't we all loved it it was
cool it was jumping Charles a big
holiday I go to deeds on like quick God
everything was huge look at my guns
everything looks different it just feels
yeah it feels different
I don't mind you right you right you
right you right you got it yeah I got my
new engine I'm cool with that but I just
hope that this one is in the right spot
you know I mean later just I just don't
want nothing to go wrong with it cuz the
parity of the gameplay you like you
don't mess up that formula right there I
see you're into your point they're kind
of doing what you want they're not doing
a completely you know next-gen based on
thing like they're keeping what they got
and it looks like they're expanding upon
it and they also look like they doing
content in content out you know I'm
saying so this is this is Connor wearing
that warframe zone I believe right yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna be here now for a
while you know I'm saying again this is
just me and a selfish techie nerds who
love when we see new when you see the
PlayStation 5 Unreal Engine revealed
right and you're talking about lumen and
they talk about all this great you're
hearing about the SSD and how it could
be utilized in all these things and then
you know a shout out to you amazed you
know as far as the PvP aspect you know
let's be real like we know one of the
problems has always been the cheating
with the first PC specific ass
and issues there so the hope was with
the new tech you kind of bring in maybe
usher and dedicated servers so I'm not
gonna lie there's a part of me that's a
little disappointed that there's no you
know not just having three for the sake
of the number three but the fact of just
saying okay we got a brand new
foundation right a brand new technical
foundation right so I but I it like you
know amazed I got confidence that they
can cuz people telling me like look you
don't miss you can still kind of rebuild
you know engine in a way so it's but
it's up to them so I'm great to do these
things correct in their hands I'm
leaving it muddies hands because listen
they'd heard they've heard so much going
on in a hurry you know and I told
anybody and everybody money ain't got a
reply to you to hear you
whatever you man situation is like hit
the ridge in PvP right now they hear you
they heard a who you that's why they ask
for feedback you need a feedback they
made a page for you to feedback some of
them are not giving feedback some of
them just you know being whiners do
constructive feedback please Lord Jesus
man just tell them this is what you
don't like Lord Jesus don't go up to
them and say you this that like God yeah
just just tell them what you feel and
what is messed up okay hit reg is a
problem okay they heard that hit reg is
a problem Daisy did the guns the balance
of the sandbox this set in the third
dedicated servers can't keep us in line
get working on these things made their
own company you expect the beaver kicks
don't expect this respect that I'm cool
with that what over there a bungee
animal not be and I'm very familiar with
it do you meet what I'm on this week let
me know because I met one I met one of
them what a torment we will all win the
game released into the tality getting it
to the Taiwan PC I'm like yeah play man
I want a PC just to forget the loading
times and the load times looking like
Kazem right now you're at the for city
he said they got a nerf the beaver I'm
done the final thing I'll say is the
most kind of good saying in chat it's
like yeah the game looks gorgeous on PC
it does like no question like people to
potentially run like 144 frames fort
Lake looks insanely good even when I was
looking at the almighty like burning out
my eyeballs I put it 255 fov and as big
as my character got the detail on the
armor got so crisp and clean it looked
so good the biggest thing like I love
how it looks feels and again Bungie is
always so much about the feel that's why
sometimes like the stats almost annoys
so much because they want things to feel
right which they nailer the biggest
thing about next-gen and this whole
engine that would like we're kind of on
is just like picture plate picture
something like the dreaming city you
have the three zones but you have to
drive between them the idea of Lake
destiny 3 would be there's no driving
between them it's just mountains over
here big Tundra in the middle this part
and it's just all connected no Indies
the look and feel of the entire game
world could potentially be different but
then on the other side which will kind
of put a pin in later so remember this
topic of conversation when we get done
with these three years we'll be at 9
years of destiny just remember how long
they play in this game to last so I want
to come back to that towards the end but
I'm just very curious to see but we got
a lot of stuff coming so very excited
but yeah 2021 like witch queen like we
finally know that Sabbath oon is gonna
be a moan and we also know each year
expansion confirms a new destination
brand new destination coming no no
rehashes or anything like that now my
hunch and apparently
just a year early is that you see
Sabbath oon I can almost bet you money
dreadknots gonna be your rehash
destination from diesel money just said
there's some I said perfect way to get
Kings full out the vault for that time
thanks for coming back indeed in 2021 I
cannot imagine a wooden leg
yeah Kings fall coming back dread not
coming back somehow tied into the story
of a Sabbath oon taking Queen however
you want to call it lonely see that one
20 22 mm I feel like that has for one
new destination not a clue but two and I
feel like that is like either thee like
the final chapter of destiny to win and
or a way for them to that's they're
probably decision time that might be the
time they do at e3 you do a light verse
a dark if you truly have that you mean
like you look at that logo go traveller
and it flips dark with the pyramid ship
over the top like that might be the time
for them to truly make that transition
but light fall that's that's a big deal
and I don't even know where we're going
for that one I wasn't a very interesting
story man very interested in what's
going now then like truly when we face
the darkness finally I feel like as a
start I don't feel like we're gonna face
face but I was just getting we're
putting our feet in the water we're
learning more about the dark right
that's what I actually I feel like when
it says light beyond it and we're doing
it there's something we're gonna be
facing is an incident in darkness but I
don't think it's gonna be we're gonna
because there's still more story to tell
about this did the darkness those
pyramids are staying those things are
something real you know I mean like out
this world right now
they that's they come in everybody
scared you know I mean like it's
something about these ships but like
they're just the the owners of destiny
like they didn't travel getting a
traveler shook everybody shook you seen
Rasputin oh Jesus everybody running I
look kind of spooky with that
because people would chat man it was
like did you see that as by the way like
real-time of likes or potential you
doing something is that Maura simulation
and then or either way like Rasputin's
in like the outcome but did you see that
is like a real-time like again maybe
using like the satellites ni out to try
and like fight back and it failed or was
that like
I feel I feel like it failed like I like
my brush speed and can't do nothing
about this you say you can take down
Almighty
but this pyramid you're on your own yeah
I mean these yeah I felt abandoned man
I felt like you'll say you're about to
get jumped and you're made you thought
your bed was right next to you you got
to take this bigger and then you look
speaking of all these pyramid ships
coming in we also have where they talked
about the game getting bigger we said
that now some people are talking about
hate Call of Duty has another 30 gig
patch it just keeps getting bigger and
people have no space on their hard
drives now I think one of the pieces of
that is not saying Call of Duty is like
an easy game to test for but they are
truly PDP they don't have random roles
like they don't have to test this they
got to make sure the map functions and
they can add stuff to the game but they
don't have to check every role in every
activity on every planet forever and
always so again it may be not like
specifically the data size but just the
number of activities for them to always
test against but the destiny content
vault the dcv I can't tell you many
times I'm probably gonna say DCP on
accident shout-out to destiny community
podcast by the way um things are gonna
be put in the destiny community vault
now we know a lot is going on the
Destiny community vault this time mainly
because the game got a bit to win up a
couple too many pant sizes we got to
drop them all at once and then they're
kind of gonna do the one in one out one
in one out two and two out basically to
cut it
once they get it where the size that
they want then they can kind of do this
even in and out switch and I wanted to
ask you guys because when you look at
the season of a rival trailer or right
bolsa Dar es you've got the idea that
the pyramid ship starts showing up on
planets first on Io
but guess what planet's leaving io next
we another one you see Mars Mars ain't
coming you see Titan Titans not coming
forward so I'm honestly wondering how
their storytelling goes this season
because wherever the pyramid ships seem
to be showing up those planets don't
make it into the fall so either we're
getting kicked out they're taking them
over I was kind of curious your thoughts
of like that connection to the pyramids
and the destiny destiny community vault
and the destinations going away like art
just linked together and then by the way
the Leviathans booking it so scale is
also given us the deuces kind of curious
you guys thoughts on the whole like they
can put it aside and Calais is going to
come back cuz Calais has got something
he's got to prove you know what I mean
Calais will be put to the side that is
the thing what Calais is coming back
he's fighting his war with us being a
leave us all we've done Calais is very
impressed by what we do and you are we
already proved our worthiness to him
he's gonna need us again he is um and
the Titan I went on Titan the other day
I'm not gonna lie that pyramid scared
the crap I didn't even know that that
thing was in the water there's a pyramid
all deep out in the water is there one
there yeah look around and I didn't spot
image shows it like mug it's like
looking right at you right right it's a
nervous do I look at I don't want to
explore anything for anybody or whatever
but it was brought to my attention I
ain't gonna say anything all i'ma just
say is mm-hmm biggest thing today
something going on oh I really think
something the the the Titans after like
is our next move because IO is this week
right yep I can feel like it's not gonna
be I of this week but like the pyramids
just gonna keep coming
we already got the pyramid oh I off for
like next week it's going to be a
different spot that that's that the
pyramids are gonna show up at and we'll
be able to see some things because these
pyramids already here they you know I
mean no it was the intro that was the
intro of the pyramids coming they made
it they finally made it here so they're
coming and it's scary man is a scary do
I I just I'm so interested in this story
line with this pyramid and what we were
like I really am I was I was so upset
just seeing one story man I'm turning
off the music I want to listen to the
story all the way through and we only
got there yeah I mean so yeah you know
what makes her funny II when I see the
pyramid over either I just feel like a
computer - I feel like yeah but when I
see that thing over that's literally
what Caleb I like we are going to see
this letter erased sued see makes our
ghost like it makes every darkness makes
everything change for us the ghost light
not again please no I mean everything
changes
get rid of your weapons get rid of this
you know what the darkness - pull up on
your plan think how this is gonna come
back I had that I had that speculation
okay he'll be a partner yeah he's got to
be a part of it man and even though I
even careless we don't even know what
the hell this truly looks like Cal is
talking to a robot's voice absolutely
all things aren't even catalyst that's
just he has so many of those bytes that
just tells me we ready to fight and
callouses ready yeah I mean that's what
makes me feels like so up here so to
ease question you know as far as the
whole um content and stuff like that
yeah like those planets are not on there
you know for everything I think you know
my guess is because it's called season
of the arrivals plural yes we are going
to have multiple things and multiple
events happen and um it's a good start
it's a good start to the season I'm just
like a mint I'm so hype I'm so wanting
this thing to move along we do got that
carrot at the end of the stick with with
your rope
so it's like you want to see how they
transition it and then from the
technical side like you were saying 'hey
you know if then it what's cool about it
is it technically they're giving a
narrative reason you have to do the
technical stuff that needs to be done
yeah and that's what I always want
destiny in doing I don't know if Attica
still in it like that's what we need we
if you're gonna do these things you just
can't wake up turn on destiny one day
the director is completely different and
planets are going why these planets
going back because you see the
gardener's pulled up you remember that
season before when they did this and
they did that and you just have this
nice continuity this narrative
continuity that
let's get right into the season real
quick I'm really enjoying the start of
this season because we're back to
strikes and stuff and like the story
were telling the story what's happening
what's going on here you know I'm saying
I love that kind of stuff as opposed to
hey just do this public event I love you
I'm saying like forget all that like I
want the this not there's something to
be said about you're playing a strike or
a story mission and the characters are
talking to you telling you what's going
on your ghost is bugging out it's it's
it's not reacting right you got the
whole seed thing what do we need this to
drift they're all these different
players coming together against this
evil you know thing that it's ominous so
I'm loving where the direction is going
I like how it should tie in you know to
everything super pumped man superb um
about what I actually do not mind the
content boat at all that was my next
question I go yeah yeah I actually don't
listen
is it a hustle yes it is a hustle but
it's a hustle that best affairs will
accept because we love remember what I
told you like they sitting we said this
a couple of hours ago they're sitting on
gold minds of content that is beloved
right right
people get mad it's all people they
remix content but if you remix the right
content when people who voted glass obey
knew which one to start with that's the
danger it's this will run so many
because it's bring it back you bring it
back some of them d1 players cuz who was
it was hooked he won you have for that
d1 cuz there's a lot of people believe
in not still played d1 because d2 is not
as exciting enough to him yeah so no one
did putting that d1 content into d2 boy
everybody you mean I mean people I've
seen say yeah I'm coming back when
September 22nd hits and is that it there
are so many people just hype I'm a boy I
took my boy I bought it and you got
hyped out of his money so you seriously
bringing it back yeah you see the
excitement when people say what volt
just come oh my god you know this is
coming back these are these are moments
yes go it's gonna be crazy the big is
that you
people have always said oh maybe he do a
rade playlist but now we've got to
answer this content vault and as long as
they're transparent as long as they're
telling us when it's going when things
are leaving that's that's amazing
transparency telling us what's going on
man so that's what ie I was curious
about what you were thinking during all
of that talk you know it's Farrakhan
content for like where's your head at
with that uh I mean it's just gotta one
of those we we knew they had been chin
it I wasn't totally surprised as to some
of it happening everybody at nailed
tight everybody's like cool we called
tighten the quantity that's going was
more than I expected
honestly they did give a couple
clarifications like exotics will be you
know there will give new ways to earn
exotic so I mean you got thorny link to
tighten you've got you know Leviathan
that's linked to frickin everything and
then it's like do I grind the hell out
of Leviathan yes thank you
are you doing this it's like and of
course we got your brand-new never seen
it cosmodrome probably the biggest
destination which is always the nice
thing to have a large one and honestly
just because I haven't seen that thing
in three years haven't seen it on PC and
it's tying into a fall expansion with
Aramis so amazing is because fallen is
freaking all over that area besides a
little bit alive and just like even as
you said it's the nostalgia just the
feels it hits you right there when you
go back in and you load it up and you
know the Cosmodrome and you're seeing
the Fallen Walker mosey on through and
the stuff that they're gonna be able to
do it that's pretty cool
they're still keep it around like
tangles for and dreaming city so I'm
wondering if there's gonna be those are
gonna be tied into the Sabbath oon story
and they're here to make sure that link
may happen kind of wonder if dreaming
cities still for that
Nessus is here but leviathans not that
was always kind of weird European can't
go anywhere because you know still earth
and then the moon was the recent
destination so I figured that would go
so I mean it kind of makes sense
honestly I'm okay like as they said like
Titan what do you go there for I
literally show up on Titan if there's er
if I need to do the the cheesy loss
sector with you know Craig and I've
known that's last time been to Titan
I've been to the tower tower I've been
maybe even a mom but I don't even know
about me no thang still exists and in
the grand scheme mercury will no longer
be the flashpoint so you don't have to
wait on the public event anymore so that
was y'all ain't God and then war mines
like escalation protocol like it'll be
kind of sad to see that one go but if
Rasputin's deuces then that planet goes
to so it's like they're given as you
said all the right narrative beats to
make like the planets that go away give
it a reason with the pyramid ships
whether they just hit the delete button
boy they take it over and you know we
have no basis there and we're getting to
new destinations and honestly just not
forcing you to go back and see old stuff
you know eat nearly as often or bring it
back two years later I'm down and then
if this is kind of the scale we get that
it cycles in and out in future
expansions I'm good and the biggest
thing is if the smaller scale of the
game helps them test faster make more
content and bring us more things quicker
that is like the biggest in game and
that part I'm completely fine with it
just to double down on em hopefully move
on is that they actually admitted to
because this game size is what it is is
that's what's causing them to be less
agile with being able to fix things and
bugs on all content so if that is truly
the reason then yes I am for this and
then make it happen I want a shot as a
big civil war going on in the chat just
oh I mean I'm reading a page here gosh
see like they they go and gosh gee I'm
feeling I'm from your school bro like
I'm from the new engine school if you
put a gun to my head that's what I'm
gonna pick every day of the week but to
Prescott's point I'm willing to see it
I'll give them a chance you know I'm
saying yes we do know there's another IP
they work it out you hope the resources
are allocated correctly we heard about
that whole thing shout out to Paul tasks
I think they're doing like a Diablo
style game Bungie is working on
something else as well matters what yeah
but what matter exactly's but if because
of the content vault and then able to
condense and to be more
and if this improves destiny then I am
with it but they've got to prove it and
then I'm ready though after life fall or
whatever what's that what's that as to
what after scarlet Falls 2020 terrier at
the left listen I still don't think it's
out of the rooms that you can still get
a new destiny game it just may not have
a number on it because at some point you
are gonna reach a threshold at some
point you know it is going to look
archaic at some point you know so I
think we can't say for certain that
there's never gonna be an upgrade you
know I'm saying so um it's a fun
discussion man I like which I'd I would
I say whoa I'm joking gosh D that did
you have really beefed it I just I'm
spice it up thought sauce on it but it's
a great discussion man I love this top
and it's fun it's fun times man
but else we got a we got stuff like the
other pieces we know cosmodromes coming
back son be real like hey your reskin an
old country guaranteed new destination
though coming with so that's at least a
nice like balance balance yeah it gives
you a fresh destination but a guaranteed
it's not just a moon it's a moon plus
brand new thing which I'm good with like
that conserve else now the other side
vault of glass obviously in the
nostalgia feels he got champions in a
raid they could see some ways they're
gonna handle that vog is gonna hit a lot
of people in the fields and they're like
cool it's coming back question lies
basically when it comes to the strikes
that are coming back seppius ball and
saber Willow rota do you okay I can hear
her sorry I see why right now like oh I
can hear the septics like old when they
do when they fix with like with rock
music brawl what I mean I did that
guitar you oh so ready but but I wanted
to ask you guys when it comes to them
bringing stuff back that d2 players a
lot of people coming to the game free
they never saw a d1 so this is stuff
what's gonna be new to them but you also
got veterans it's like literally all of
us probably a lot of the people and Chad
have been playing dusty for a while if
you go back and you cease epics early
are you like first time hey it's kind of
cool but then it's just in that strike
playlist and you're running it on the
night falls again you're like I've done
this before I wanted to just actually
has thoughts on bringing back strikes
now obviously we got to see new strikes
and these fall expansions like
if they don't give us some that'll be an
issue and I might dole these strikes out
like one a season to give us you know a
bit more content there but I wanted to
see just when it like even stuff like
strikes and just using more old content
how do you think if you're cool with it
you see the community like going all up
in arms like oh you're just reusing old
stuff again as opposed to giving us new
stuff just thoughts on the strikes
because that's that might be a little
less like beloved than vogue mmm all
right yet again some people aren't happy
with I'll be honest with you know some
people wanted to old rather old con to
be scrapped bringing some new stuff they
feel like people just feel like bunches
running out ideas and I look at it like
this and I try to explain so a lot of
people in chat that hey they're not
running out ideas this is just what the
community wants to see they want right
all of this stuff back this is what they
want because everybody wants to relive
this and they want to relive that and
the old content to me that's to me right
now coming into D 2 that is means a
definitely new content cuz it's coming
on to a new engine which is destiny to
engine off that D one engine and it
could be the same experience is the one
doing this stuff in d2 so to me that is
new content vex mythoclast and fate
bring are coming into D - that is new
content dangling is not going to feel
the same way it felt one we just got
confirmation of weapons of vogue come to
life why we're up a new info like these
things that people wanted in rates
they're gonna get in this vault of glass
that means that they want it it's gonna
be in the vault of glass and it might
not even be the they even told you it's
not even be the same fill of that raid
you got unstoppable champions it's gonna
be imagine what they're going to add
unstoppable champions you want to have
some issues one it might be much harder
than what you thought before and he
might even add a normal in heart like
they did for the old raids these things
that give you the guns that you wanted
Mandy adapt version of the Fate bringer
and these things just there's so many
things that people miss down on will you
see it in d2 and you wanted that fate
bring gonna have that art to it when it
puts you in that exotic class and make
you choose fate bring is gonna do some
work vision of confluence it is revenge
you got freakin what else the pataw
reinforced so many weapons that y'all
about the tests and then the vex
mythoclast Lord Jesus have a net in d2
y'all talking about
they're bringing old content from the
deal as it breaks a lot of stuff can we
not have to fusion rifles the play
lesson from d1 and so now when they put
it in d2 if I feel like it's going to be
better managed not being it every weapon
like it was and d1 where it was you know
they had to nerve that thing quit like
whoa whoa no they were none of them but
I say look it's still new content to me
maybe hold this yeah he's stuck at our
table
okay the thing of a situation is to me
is what I'm saying is that the contents
not old it's it's not it's it's old but
it's not old I don't know how to explain
it but it's still different things
because you're good you're going to
still enjoy it it's still new content
sitting there along with the old content
that the people so to you it's old but
so new players who've never played it's
new you know I mean we have more people
coming into this platform each and every
day since that announcement your people
asking should they get it should they
not get it I tell them yeah you should
get it get an experience and get a feel
of the game now instead of waiting until
September it's a power level up so you
can be balanced with everybody else in
destiny versus you you know what I mean
for us
Hawk oil players of course I mean it's
old all right we know about it but the
new I want people this is what
experience I want people to experience
that's all I wanted I said next
generation of kids party is man let's
make them feel let's make these people
like the game gonna be honest builder
was the play from the cosmodrome and i
was just i was nothing yummy but it's
the whole deal of it is in a situation
is like just make people feel good about
the game because the only the the game
is never gonna be fun for anybody and
that could be any game if you're playing
by yourself so get your friends your
family man and just have fun I mean I
can't wait to explain its content to new
people and tell them stories about what
I've been through and destiny and what
we went through cuz I'm gonna tell you
I've been here by Millea oh this is new
I'm like wow I've been here before
I wasn't written here so yeah I can't
wait old Russia I'm ready
yeah so we got a couple dates when they
talk about stuff returning so year four
starts September 22nd cosmodrome will be
an explorable destination but not yet a
full Destiny one like copy their games
to kind of let the new light players
experience more
the initial story and cosmodromes will
of crota strike will be added to the
strikes for all players during season 13
picture that December time frame
cosmodrome will be flushed out to
roughly d1 parody devil's lair and fall
and saber comeback desk during gear for
sometime over the course the year vog
returns so there's a bit of spacing to
those now picture this year season to
the worthy but the only other thing they
add bug so if they have that spring
doldrums but they can drop fog in the
middle of that that is gonna be fine
that helps them tremendously because dad
has been let's be real that's been the
Achilles heel of the seasonal content
model you know we have these very
smaller content drops some like these
another where they don't but but you
know do it now you could say okay let's
pull something out the vault narrative
Lee user you don't have to necessarily
create a new asset right like you can
you can use something that you got and
then you could if they tie it in
narrative Lee and cool
you can now beef up these smaller parts
by going back and forth and out of your
vault so it does give them potential you
know I'm saying and I think it really
does help them from an agility
standpoint it this could be used I like
that thought process I think this could
really be used because let me really
we've know September's are always lit
yep always like the history of destiny
you know September is coming it's gonna
take your life over that's what we do
but the season pass yet it's been very
hit and miss some seasons is okay you
know some seasons like last and then you
know so it we need to beat those up to
keep that engagement going so yeah I'm
excited for the potential of that I
think that could be cool I do too man I
think that's an amazing experience yeah
couple things for year 4 so we know deep
stone crypt is the raid obviously saying
that one again there will be new ways to
earn exotics originally tied to
destinations and activity content that
have entered the vault so as we pictured
Thor and they're gonna you know sleeper
catalyst all that stuff they're gonna
find new ways to do it whether just
world drops or whatever
available strikes also go so anything
tied to that distant destination truly
goes weapons quest strikes so I mean
we're losing two strikes on Mars two
strikes on Mercury Rossen Titan we lose
one strike and what stable on Io
we're losing festering core and I feel
like we just got it yeah I feel like we
just got it so it's that's a fair chunk
of the strike playlist now I know
they're kind of do that nightfall the
ordeal stuff but that like written the
standard strike playlist definitely
gonna shrink cuz we're not getting that
many strikes back in a September
expansion they'll can dabble a couple
throughout but we're definitely gonna be
losing some they said the PDP map
playlist will remain a curated best of
destiny one and two mixture there Kevin
as they said they're kind of bring in
pvp maps in and out so they cycle them
through gambit and gambit prime as they
told us merged into a single mode with
the original armor vais visuals
available to earn from the drifters so
game ins being plugged into one mostly
kena that they taught us mm-hmm so yeah
I mean the game is gonna look different
if you've seen a picture of the director
Nessus your OPA Vanguard gambit crucible
tower EDC and even if we go in Cosmo
domes really not gonna be a big deal for
much stuff it sounds like at the
beginning so EDC necess Europa moon
Dreaming City and tangled sure it's
definitely gonna shrink so I kind of I
will be curious how it how it feels
we're gonna be loosened how many raids
were losing yeah sorrow predicted this
who told people to raids is going I
called it everybody was like I told you
they was setting us up I do it was have
to look at but Haven what about most
like they're they're keeping the gun in
the game but they're also taking the
whisper mission out we talked about that
too because I was going yeah yeah quest
like certain beloved things are hmm
they're going so it's like it's sad to
see whisper go it's sad to see some of
these rates go well the exotic the exact
stock but the exotics are gonna see a
sunset I'm telling you it's gonna happen
I think I think at this point I have to
I think that it's as much as I don't
want this to go and I don't I think then
literally it's like you want you want to
get the mob to do what you want them to
do you know saying you can't just shock
value just take things away and I think
then literally setting that spot
little by little you know the kind of
like the easy log to where they really
want us to go and I see it you know you
know how strongly I feel about that
we're not gonna get into that right now
but you know at the end of the day I I
kind of called it I think this is their
vision I will say this the only thing I
will say is I understand the asset part
but it would have been kind of cool if
they could find a way for the just for
the Vanguard strike playlist because now
that those strikes are going out it's
all numb that to fill this back up with
substantial content and let's be real
like unless it's tied to the planet from
a technical standpoint and they just
can't do it
I was hoping that strikes would just
have this plethora of strikes you're
saying to go in there and just see
they'll see different things so I'm a
little sad about it I got to see how
that's handled I believe I'm not really
thrilled that those strikes are going
cuz I was hoping that strikes would stay
and you take the planning I don't care
about the planet nobody using the money
over there but you know I was hoping it
strikes this table where we'll see man
but I told you I man they gonna be
taking this stuff away man that means my
by Leviathan
it was soon was a good run i'ma miss you
man when we're standing on them plates
melting Calais i'ma miss it man you get
rid Jarls already I do then you set us
up I was like I'm not being fooled by
the glitz and the glam of everything
else but look at the end of the day they
over here The Magicians misdirection yep
they really got me I ain't
it's like yeah you can't fault but guess
what you're that kid no more everything
is about that time you know there's
things that think about like analysis
related to the red war the read war has
got like the original campaign going
through Titan going through IO you do a
little unnecessary and stories so then
if new light players come in the
stranger who is in d1 I swear they could
almost I am into d1 and then you go
straight into beyond light with the
stranger story and Eris is a Saracen The
Drifter might be like where the hell do
you guys come from but it's kind of like
if you think about a lot of the d1
stories you can almost like lift them
out and they don't overall in the big
arc they don't have as much connection
to some of the bigger dis a buffoon Oryx
hive darkness pyramids yeah they're kind
of this like they're separate it's like
in its it fits that it's actually almost
like that stuff that's going because
then they almost kind of build them they
start connecting narratives that are
almost not connected to those because
even like forsaken didn't really connect
with the red war like the Revolution got
me back up in these seasons and we're
like are we done with you guys yet
they're just they're finally leaving yes
please yeah yeah exactly
please no doubt what else we got so we
got big trailer DC V we got three years
of stuff we got new rates we got over
eights all that stuff's going on and
that was even before we're like oh yeah
you're about to go play the new season
in like 20 minutes
including this trailer was going on and
we got season of arrivals and we got the
trailer about that we got the tease of
the pyramid ship flying over the tease
of your opens coming you got the giant
these things are massive by the way the
experiment ships are huge and I don't
even know if these are the big ones but
they're like hey let me just take up
half your skybox view of ya ages are the
skybox Chile mmm-hmm and while like hey
the pyramids are coming in we got the
new public event which is pretty cool
the fact that they're like hey by the
way there's a new dungeon dropping in
seven hours I know out of my
bye-bye I think that dungeon that blew
me man I was high I have to give the
full story of the dungeon so we can talk
about this like that properly thanks the
cosmos tweet and some people were asking
do two triumphs tied to specifically the
season we're making some changes under
the hood - how activities function would
be in season 12 launches which we hope
results in no noticeable changes to the
activities themselves unfortunately that
change means our newest pinnacle
activity prophecy may have to take a
season off before it returns working
bringing it back as quickly as possible
so they have a dungeon by the way free
to every single player you could be free
and playing a dungeon which is never
done before but it is gone away at the
end of the season so chesty it's it's
altered already io I haven't finished
the dungeon I've jumped in it a little
bit but I've only heard just absolutely
amazing things about this place mm-hmm
for one just thoughts on just the
seasonal arrivals in the new dungeon
everything amazed just like when you got
to the second half of this information
and now we're in the midst of it like
what are you feeling on the season so
far you're a few days in you have been
grinding like no life and this thing I
know you have so how's the season
treating you so far like I'm on vacation
this is the only vacation I get doing
this this come on it season so yeah I
definitely know liked it it's amazing I
actually enjoyed I tell everybody I
enjoy the season whatever we gotta come
in I enjoy it I like IO I liked the
story
I liked it going through there and
experiencing cuz I don't know if anybody
else felt this I was trying to get my
chat to to remind me where it came from
but we go into that story and and in
that pyramid takes us into that area it
reminds me of an old story mission in d1
I just can't think of it what you had to
jump across the platforms to activate
the the the doors you know what I'm
talking about we played it in d1 you
jump across to it kill the witch like
normally and I was like man
this thing is up DejaVu is this feels
like a story mission in d1 and it is I
just can't figure out what it is but it
templete takes me back to d1 we
definitely visited something from d1 in
this story mission um and I guess going
into you know the the Isles contact is
what they call it public of it give it
aa and I enjoyed it and and I didn't
know you could make it Reutemann to like
a day or two later um but um the dark
engrams I like it I like the fact that
there's Prime in s dark and you decide
through what weapons you want to get in
armor your FS
yeah I love that I love that feel about
it every bit the dungeon
I think I'll spoil it for no one but
it's a fun thing I've already knew yeah
it's not it's it's arrived for at one
point I know that part I just say
alright okay good it was was a was a
good dungeon I
I expect more I expect more dungeons as
bunnies just show talent right there
with that dungeon um showing what they
can do that dungeon did some amazing
things for a lot of people you've heard
a good feedback from everybody who's
experienced it and me myself I I love it
man um but the other things that they
got coming
um I enjoyed it so far man the power
level of the power Brian a lot of people
are still grinding out the trials comes
in and then lockout honey-do about ten
times all the way like yep they're not
go look where the trials go yeah it's
going ladies and gentlemen no one child
over
do they could take a game Oh as quick as
the lighthouse wasn't working they
disappeared so that tells you budgie has
major control move a lot of things that
they can do just like that if a game
mode is really really bad you never
gonna handle it but if it's not really
really bad as you think in this like
that money could they know how to turn
stuff off and you know I mean but this
one was a serious deal go on to the
lighthouse was a big deal I'm just glad
I got my power was out before I shut
down so far I should go but I can say
overall about this season and so far
what I've been thinking of it I like you
man I enjoyed it seems like a lot of
other people also enjoy as some people
just not with the you know they're not
with the season things you know like
that they want to wait for a big season
so what you think me
oh you first man just in general to
where we just like these don't have
arrivals just tell me the Ryan so far
just everything there I have the trailer
the fact that it's a new dungeon if you
tried the publican just kind of full
season vibe since we're in the house
tonight it's been good I've been liking
it you know I'm saying I'm cool with the
was good to hold the quarter thing we
don't wait up what oh boy I get from me
though I think I'm a huge fan of
starting new season like what story
mission and I think that's what this did
well we jump right to it you don't need
Aris gotta find out what's going on with
her
I love the net it felt like a strike it
felt like I missed that I missed I don't
like just starting the season and then
you know we've depositing fraktur line
and like there's no like I like
narrative lead-up you know like one
night that's what me you know what you
call it when we say for say 14 yes oh oh
right or amazing into it yeah like that
get got to do that I think the mistake
worthy did is yeah they had a little
cool cinematic but did it was just
really mess with these Rasputin nodes
and all this other stuff and and we got
to get back to the core gameplay of
these story missions and strikes and
stuff like that so I love that I liked
that fight you know with the Sabbath on
witnesses and
jumping from the the little towers of
splitting self are I thought the strikes
were well I mean the story missions are
well done like well they're cool strike
yeah yeah it would be a cool try I love
the little moving pen I loved it the
mechanics were ending that was Kings
fall hopping on those like giant
swinging you know I did that bad boy
solo man I had so much fun doing it and
um so you got that we get into the arm
oh let's get right to it though
where the Horde is out here for guys if
you ain't running with a hood you ain't
doing it right
this season ever that's the arrival the
arrival of what I didn't think this
thing would be so dominant like it is
the multi-purpose everydays is to do
matter I wanted to it you it's literally
she changes name like this thing drops
that taken pool on the ground killing up
enemies yo you don't even wanna use this
in control and control it is so
disgusting like you can literally put
like a bunch of toys like like math
control and PvP it is rock solid PvP
Horrigan huh the pot and you could if
you up close and you aim down sight you
could what it if you're close enough you
could dislocate it up directly if you
hit them directly they'll die from it
yeah yeah cuz it'll siphon the siphon is
there later I know this gun is so out of
control but I love it it's like I can't
get it out of my lineup but only thing
is that I got to get this exotic thing
noise I've been working for that I guess
it's the catalyst for it when you're um
yeah you got it do the Guardian kills I
got to do it but actually I'm not that
intimidated because of how many multi
kills I get with this thing so I'll run
that and I've run on my interference and
the other giant mine where the hordes
out here yeah
what's he said what's the exotic perk
for it what no I want to know what the
perk does when you unlock it you always
want to know did you guys hear
always oppose the rhetorics and has 75
kills with it in catch yeah I got a
boost salute the rhetoric regex needed
this man we don't want the life of that
rhetorics man by the way all right
Greece's whither hordes handling and
gives it autoloading holster whoa oh
yeah man that's gonna be so good
Oh Otto Lord ago holster alone and yeah
that's what I'm thinking of the
autoloading holster that's all lobsters
by the way they brought back truth
teller the branch flowed as well and
somebody got they were telling me they
got feeding frenzy on breach load put
those two together fire get a kill fired
and faster reloading faster get a kill
like and it's just this perpetual cycle
with a great feeling at the top yeah
crazy right now it's with especially
like with ads just melting stuff so it's
interesting and that I got a bow with a
couple of the new perks both actually at
the same time we got unrelenting and
then killing wind I got both on the same
be a nice killing wind final blows drain
increased mobility weapon range and
handling for a short time and rapidly
defeating targets triggers health
regeneration Guardians and powerful
combatants count as more so if you get a
kill in PvP quicker handling weapon
ranged like all that at the same time
somebody who's good with bows is
probably gonna be scary with that thing
I'm sure so the combination some of
these perks are they're fun now I don't
know if you guys peaked until you guys
want to know what the iron banner perks
are yeah III do I don't tell them they
know hi so amazed oh we won't we won't
if you want to if you want it all go
ahead
I don't play I don't believe I'm banner
so and like get me in tell me what what
it is what are the perks cuz I don't
plan on better is it worth me playing on
banner cuz I can't play on better man
let me look let me look hold on I gonna
get the guns are you to why you're
fighting that yo gosh D so you say be
careful rhetoric someone on another
stream said that they did not get regex
from a thousand talkers I have to happen
to cook yeah I will say this I haven't
gotten an extra rederick since this new
season cuz I want oh like it's a vapor
yeah because the weapon the world
loophole like normally it checks yeah
you unlocked it you would keep getting
roles yeah yeah anymore I haven't tried
but I haven't seen one pop up this
season I haven't seen one pop up yet so
that is interesting but cuz I did is one
I think I wanted gives a perfect
adjustability buff as opposed to the
default one that they give you
yeah I'm at the Duster Fredrickson when
I'm done with more with the hoard
but yeah what you see with this uh okay
so we got iron grip and iron gay so they
mentioned they were coming thanks to
light GG if you don't want to know sorry
spoilers I'll wave my hands when we're
done do you want to skip ahead Brian
give it just a couple minutes so you've
got two options
iron grip massively improves weapons
stability plus 20 at the cost of reload
speed minus 40 oh wow that's a huge
disparity okay yeah that's the ability
you reload speeds gonna be like hold on
let me check the serial number and they
like to load the bullets individually
yeah that'll be slow was that one's not
so bad
mm-hmm this one I don't know sure about
I some gays now this comes on an auto
rifle by the way both of these do it I
think there's one other
Massell improves weapon target
acquisition aim assist plus it's funny
Wow and it takes it and it takes it from
71 it would take it up to 91 you can
throw target acquisition probably be a
hundred what it is at the cost of weapon
range and it is minus 40 that's a lot of
range right and it's only got 50 on this
auto rifle there's I think another
weapon that might have it but plus 20 a
missus minus 40 range
it's a 600 rpm auto
that's kind of crazy yeah it comes with
the curated is dynamic sway and iron
gaze so you got the minus 40 range 20 M
assist you got to be close
but apparently you won't miss if you're
close like a submachine gun up close
yeah interesting very valid to want it
like if they're gonna make you a little
more powerful they seem to also want to
make think about what's the
give-and-take say I just like to cross
those one at so we'll see what iron
banner happens who knows when that will
come it's coming and then for the season
just the general rundown we've got the
calendar grants honestly it's pretty
front-loaded mm-hmm so we've got June
9th obviously would happen already
contact arrives on IO BB he activity
doing our public event thing June night
six hours later or 7 dungeon happens
that's here all season sadly it's
leaving at the end of the season so get
your butt in there and level up yeah I
got I gotta get into here June 9th we
got the mission interference and the
weekly quest that will do kind of
dealing with whatever's happened there
you can actually get pinnacle from that
which is cool mm-hmm the only other two
things besides the and more is July 7th
so a month later through September 22nd
basically what is that like almost three
months July August and September almost
the entire time until we get beyond
light moments of triumph is going on
mm-hmm
well that's gonna be new triumphs new
seals coursing get your new shirt which
you and I have we're half of these
podcast yes and then August 11th through
September 8th about four weeks give
Soulstice each two heroes again till the
free event for all players new glowing
legendary armor hopefully don't screw a
side of the armor 2.0 stuff again okay
and that's it that is literally the only
thing they got new PD activity new
dungeon you know weapons ranks and all
the basic bullet points on the top and
we got our unreal engrams which is kind
of its own thing that's not listed here
because you got the specialization focus
but it's there's not a lot here to know
now you know there are multiple planets
potentially these things are going to
show
up on and they have that little trailer
but as we don't have a whole lot to go
off on what do you guys do you guys
think it will be a front-loaded season
do you guys think they will are they
gonna do like a two-week spacing and
like eight weeks later we're gonna
finally begin to see in a pyramid ship
on like Mars or something like that
kinda wanted to see your guys thoughts
of how the season might go but ya know
I'm thinking yeah when I big-deal seated
this is coven it's definitely gonna be
fully loaded with some stuff like in
this this thing requires a lot of memory
no I think everything's gonna be I think
that bungees going to do something right
this time on this one by letting
everybody experience and give them a lot
because we have been getting these
little teas four teats Four Seasons and
stuff like that um I think they want to
get this is this is obviously you paying
seventy bucks or something like this
would definitely just expect a lot on in
this game um that's how I look at it you
pay the bunny the price gets back then a
lot of it so I see a lot coming on the
forefront of this of this new season
that they're dropping it's coming in so
I feel good I'm ready I don't think it's
gonna be I hope they don't I hope they
don't like or gate it like don't get it
don't get it time time things and just
just let that one happen you know what I
mean okay okay that's how you go yeah
this is interesting I mean I know that
obviously with the big one
and what we don't get but this this
season is looking at that road map
obviously we got it done I was surprised
I got the dungeon so fast I was too I
ain't no I wasn't mad not not that I'm
mad normally you would I would figure
they would have built that up a little
too weak cadence or a couple weeks in
and there's a leveling going yeah
because I'm trying to defend I'm like
well you need to stretch out some
content we will wait for that it doesn't
say like a couple of weeks no I was
gonna say who are the dungeon haven't
beat it yet but it is like prophecy land
dealing with the nine that's about all I
know yes a team of a place when we win
it right for like I saw like the first
tidbit and saw the first little kind of
boss fight action angle I know you're
not gonna say anything but as literally
the title is prophecy is this something
that specifically they they want to kind
of start kind of building threads for
the fall as that kind
like tying in to what you see coming is
there any relation of the story you see
to what we kind of have been told is
coming don't tell us what happens but do
you see a connection like a gem yes yes
just make sure you listen though cuz
okay I don't want to miss it just it's a
yellow and listen just look a catalyst k
don't know your subtitles if you can't
read
oh you're so - okay fair enough fair
enough yeah that's kind of why I was
wondering about the dungeon be in theirs
because it may not be as tied to
specifically the darkness but it's like
us little connection with The Drifter
till like T's the story so you get to
when you can I don't think it's as
connected to the rest of the story that
was why I was curious so you did confirm
but I can't wait to play it yeah like I
said I just hoped that you'd obviously
definitely front-loaded you know we got
to see how they handle the gaps towards
the end of this specific season and just
make sure tie-in I'm I'm gonna assume
more dark darkness is coming we will see
I think they got stuff they're sitting
on that they probably want to secretly
introduce and you know they're not
really they're not willing to put that
on the map just like let's be real we
didn't even know the name of this season
and stuff until the day of and I think
because of the way this season ties into
the narrative beats for the future
they don't want to give it away they
don't want to spoil by having this stuff
on the map cuz let's me ref we quit
heard season of rivals we know damn near
what the contents about now is it so it
the way they're doing it I think is
because things are so direct we're so
close to these bigger events they just
kind of want to keep the secrecy going
you know and I'm cool with it I'm
actually cool it yeah I kinda wish and I
know they cat said literally in the fall
this stuff's going away but it would be
kind of funny if the pyramids like
progressed and all of a sudden two weeks
later I was out like if they started
dropping playing alone I need I need to
delete pull a bunny there it would be if
they didn't tell people people would
lose their mmm
mind though but it would be cool in the
game yes I just lost the planet what uh
yes very easy and cool but piss people
have at the same time but I still like
to see it happen did the cinema lag goes
on a week ago and you see this do you
see that you were you blogging you see
that and then the planet is gone or some
type of explosion that would be funny I
go I would I would like to see something
like that hilarious it goes to Mars and
I was just like kind of grayed out gnome
what you cannot know there it's like
what bags would I be so dope man so much
got some ideas I I will say one small
shout-out to the artifact it's a step in
the right direction for the gauntlet mod
for pulse rifles where you can use any
pulse rifle as a champion breaker yes
that is a direction because I've been
dying for those things to be usable yeah
put that into a to other posters like
outbreaks I actually wish I could do
that because we believe that yeah but
that's one thing I've been asking for
mazes like all I think every weapon
should have that like mod slot even if
you can't put like extended mag on and
exotic at least let me use like you know
just raw never ever on it yeah yeah that
make sense right
it makes yeah so there's maybe calling
for cuz I can't look in the game but
it's a mod gauntlet mod and it allows
you to use and it makes your pulse rifle
rifle be I think it's disruption I can't
remember which one or overload but it
just is for any pulse rifle because it's
an armor mod so you can use exotics
because it's just it's a most anything
works thank you it's an eight I use
caught overloads so I keep news about
outbreak problem with no that's what we
want to that's the idea you can use
outbreak
with the goggles and armor yeah that's
what it worked that so that was like it
there's step in the right direction now
that's what I'm talking about that oh
yeah let's go I love you too gave me
ideas I got ideas now yeah I got ideas
hold my lord I totally slept on that
know something man I talked to you about
all these they called you out man called
you may know Rico didn't tell me I'm
upset yeah I'm in a bag come on wait the
lock that I have definitely a lock event
that's or so oh I can see that on our
break I love that that's what I see some
people want to contact using I'll break
and I'm looking and like a hi you're not
doing nothing but man was i lying
everything okay so on this on now no I'm
saying yeah and I was like we had more
trailers hype and everything we don't
even have time to talk about the
PlayStation stuff because that is crazy
yes but yeah as you said people went to
go play trials today starting off a new
season and that down I just wanted to
get you guys thoughts on seriously the
fact that like trials is off like you
guys I think I was gonna say do you guys
think even though the flawless isn't
available they should leave it there or
do you think there's potentially too
much past backlash because people may
not get the message that you won't get
the flawless chest they just were like
screw it we'll just take it out and
wondered you guys thoughts heard kind of
both ways about it well we we need to I
needed I need to go ahead and jump down
to the point in this is their adapt
weapons and a flawless just everybody's
like damn not using it not bring a deaf
stuff a while like season 13 yeah here's
the case flawless
it's whatever you know I mean it's it's
a piece of gear it if they made it there
in a sense of all fairness thing yes you
should give them the flawless even if
they don't go to the lighthouse and go
get it at least put it in a postmaster
to say this is what you got because it
does show in the stats on the e Lo and
you went flawless I have it in - as I
went flawless today and so just look at
the people who've gotten the flawless
and just give them the pinnacle and what
in a postmaster or something like that
make it fair for them so yes I I agree
with that I mean a lot of people wasn't
expecting a shutdown matter of fact a
lot of people were waiting but I was a
gay some people don't really care about
that power level as some people think of
it as a skill versus lovely you know I
mean so yeah I mean I'm proud that
budget shut it down if you can't get to
the lighthouse this is just give a
chance to all the people as I said
earlier to grind more get your power
level up cuz a lot of people didn't meet
the standards and it was they were gonna
face a lot of people that was really
really high you know didn't 60-something
already yeah yeah it's it's nuts
so there's a lot of people that I wasn't
ready for the situation if he wasn't
like me and just no brain did like the
whole entire week and the trials was not
gonna be a thing for you at least this
week get yourself some time over the
weekend - I'm proud of this this just
gives a lot of people time over we can
get the grind going keep on getting the
grind on and try to get their power
level up cuz mm-hmm they gonna need it
people are trying to play it today at
10:16 and just getting smacked on body
shouting people with them a Bolger and
killing them in one shot
it's embarrass all three people in New
Orleans they quit
because this first week is heavy
grinders otherwise you made it stay
clear Jeff what said he said basil it
was a child like a red boss oh my god
Lee I can be shut down so I don't know I
wouldn't hear and easily Smasher so
knows I was surprised I mean I didn't I
mean obviously you know when I broke the
news to me so I didn't know what was
going on yeah you got the vampire arrows
over here so I know you wake up getting
ready to podcast feel like you probably
missed this tweet so I drop it entirely
free a free stream discard these like
what like yikes it's kind of
unprecedented but I think the biggest
thing is I was saying some people like
hey why not why not let us go for the
three it would be nice not everyone
follows Bungie on Twitter they can't
potentially get the message in there and
if somebody who doesn't follow Twitter
but say hey I got my three people let's
play and they don't check they get
flawless and they're pissed there's
gonna be more of that pushback that
would go poorly I think and so it's a
Bungie safer way just to say take it out
we will fix it smarter I don't know what
happened what happened all right so you
know what what would the commotion went
on for one I was already prepared for
trials early this morning and yes I used
to go yeah I was actually sitting ready
to rock and roll had the people would
have been there and people coming in my
chat said the line I was bugged at first
I didn't believe it you know I thought
it was a joke my house is so right yeah
I made it to the lighthouse and we click
and we literally just say honey do every
time oh really and well literally you
can't click it as many times you want
you're just gonna get honeydew honeydew
honeydew honeydew honey do you can
switch characters come back click it
again it didn't even do the animation
for the ship to go to mercury it would
go literally black out and say honey do
the troll I was like oh man I guess I'm
not the brute-force through here like I
try to
[Music]
the situation um but you can still I did
not I wasn't upset you could still get
two drops three five and seven you still
got the summit of the rocket in the
Astra resin is given weapons this week
so this was definitely helping the
weapon side of our leveling and I like
the Biden complain I actually liked you
get a lot of unreal dark engrams from it
as well as well awesome elements so as
soon as though let me I should his
minute so at the three win and the five
windmark because they said they had
update are you getting any mass to work
mature I heard they supposed to be add
in that did they added I got enhancement
prism as well so what I wanted three mmm
and I went at five and fr I guess we
made it consistent dropping that's
definitely orangey style I love the way
they play like that you only get the
window it doesn't give you a game yeah I
heard they had a new bounty say had a
new bounty do you have to do bounty they
say for um that's a lie you don't need a
hit legend to go and play trials at all
well that I was I'm not seeing the other
okay what's her that he's got to do
bounty now that whatever if you if you
just play yes award if you're asking for
that it gives you a reward it gave me a
rocket after I completed one of the that
bounty oh that was my for what I got for
it got you randomized gosh oh okay okay
that's what all right so I'll be before
the light heart started being filled
with honeydew and beavers um it was all
good until you got today you know I'm
saying so he was getting it three wins
and people coming over from PC say hey
maze you wanna see and no probably I by
the hitter right now yep nope I need you
got you okay alright the deste say you
know what let's just shut this thing
down till we okay yep and then when I
went to click it again I was like what
am I gonna try what strolls
so now is just gone from the play there
was but I literally watch it go away
that's great I had to go look again to
make sure I wasn't I wasn't losing my
mind cuz it was just there you know I
mean so I look that was way to go then I
told everybody a check I didn't expect
the lighthouse to be bugged that was the
last thing on my mind I mean because I
thought lighthouse was just the same
regular thing but you have people in
chat saying it add up weapons was
supposed to drop in this one right to
get excited but it's not this shit's not
we're still a little bit away though I
did find a picture of the trials access
to do quest for this season to get into
it when it gets fixed so you've got
reach power level 1010 which again the
heaters seem to be okay you have to rate
reach valor rank of legend you have to
plate enough matches to get to legend
really that's actually some time and you
got to defeat 50 opponents now it's
retroactive so if you've done it on your
character it's there but if it's a new
account they still have to play enough
Valor to get to legend so it's a start
to start slowing somebody's like that
might be over to hold I don't know man
if this is for for cheaters yeah we got
it might be over to hold but you got
think about it she does make enough
money to just cause like a people the
price of the counts that they buy my
goal that's not helping that's not gonna
be enough for cheaters like yeah people
accent for a payroll or ass employ do a
paid thing for trials that's not going
to work yeah you need a system to
counter these cheaters maybe they need
to catch that up a wall is not going
stop cheetahs they're just gonna buy it
and play unless you are able to catch
her that count and take pitches like I
don't want to feel like I have to keep
taking pitches and try to get somebody
bad that should be something like a
maintenance system should be able to
catch if you were able to shoot 30,000
shots you automatically be being really
good if you're able to shoot 30,000
shots in a rocket launcher then the
security systems to automatically bang
no one should be shooting that many
shots that quick you know you have the
decoder though I still agree that they
need to do something with like how call
of duty's doing it right now
are they doing a two-factor
authentication man dedicated you know
anti cheat system and I ate it and
talked about that e they didn't talk
about no on none of the streams and then
III gotta get answers on that I was like
ap big you know reveals that's that's a
different time that's that's a different
article but it's like yeah they're yes
it's they're aware but they're not gonna
be like hey every is really excited by
the way we know cheating so happen hey
let's have this crappy different tones
in different like discussions I gotta be
for me some we need to get in there and
fix this thing man but you know overall
you know they here they had to shut this
thing down obviously you know based on
what you guys telling me now it makes
sense and I just I just don't want it to
be a situation where it's gone mad weeks
you know I'm saying like I don't think
that's the case I just think it was just
bug today and they can you know I don't
want to get that
I'm not gonna but you know what I do I
have this way of saying you know what
guys we we just felt it was best if we
take it out completely awaits exactly so
I'm not gonna put their energy out but I
just hope that this could be resolved
fairly quickly because they're people we
still like it shouting we've got
everybody on console but you know we try
to keep it positive because if that
happens chat I apologize I just want to
help you guys child doesn't hurt me so
if it doesn't come back it's okay but
some of these PvP players are going a
massive like riot when stuff like that
happens so home is just a lighthouse bug
and it's not enough to wait bugs the
whole entire trows gaming thing on
weekends that's gonna suck again for
them to wait that long but it's just I'm
just hoping it's just a tiny like yeah I
just hope this boom little hotfix we get
a little surprise right right right
that's all I'm thinking of something you
know but I'm gonna keep it I'm gonna
keep you thought in here too because
that might hurt I was like I think I
feel like I've gotta be forgetting
something and all this but mmm I feel
like we've touched a lot so you mean we
got three years of destiny we got stasis
a new subclass element however that's
tight and everything will give probably
more clarification later mm-hmm
we got destiny content vault five
destinations going away cosmodrome
coming back to kind of built throughout
the year as it goes to get fleshed out
we got new season arrivals dungeon drop
in seven hours later like holy crap
people beaten it esoteric RT so loaded
with one hand tied behind his back
hopping on one foot cuz he's crazy I so
thank you man
and then you know the issue with trials
the bunt the debt the debt good off the
dungeon having to leave kind of a couple
a couple you know knocks at the legs
there as it's like they're just like
building all this hype and they I got a
couple hits to take right there so right
it's been a really weird week and then
PlayStation doing the same thing pipe
trailer for all the stuff and then just
cognate I've been talking about this a
lot if you guys don't know like
spider-man Miles Morales were like cool
two different ideas like is this an
expanded thing is this a little bit in
DLC or in my mind is it a full game it's
kind of in-between it's a smaller stand
it's just like clear messaging on that
one would have been it's just been a
it's been an interesting weeks that I
said that I was like when we forgot
about the almighty I was like that it's
been a hell of a week yeah we had a lot
going on and it's just light and
lighting just I just wanted one of your
vapor Mario origami King yeah one was
like a different battle sister I like
Mario RPG is like one of my OG RPGs as
well so the legends are set up stars
that's a good one destiny has sucked me
in man I know I'm upset sometimes cuz
there's other games but Destiny's just
got me man no I can't get away from me
man I'll be honest it's the only game I
play I can't play like my issues I just
don't have enough time to make the
videos I don't wanna make in place I
gotta try and do both but ya know it's
it's it's in a good spot and the fall is
I gotta keep expectations as always but
I mean from what I saw and especially is
it small expansion time brah I mean oh
my hype is high my hype is huge right
now I was I was just giddy on stream
when we were reveal mmm I lost my mind
it was just so good idea to man we were
all on the same boat man boy
she is be honest to be honest like I
know I'm such a fan boy when I saw the
stream I'm thinking to myself like just
the hawk or gonna be embracing this and
loving and going crazy but when I see
Twitter and I see the casuals and I see
people who haven't played in a while say
yo I saw the trailer yo I'm in and I'm
like yeah like that's not like that made
me feel good because again I'm so used
to you know this is all love that I know
I'm gonna go crazy but to see the effect
yeah of the community or people who
haven't played destiny by other people
who are like y'all I'm checking this out
man I like the features and a lot of
people were hitting me back hIgG asking
me questions like should I jump in back
now should I wait like I'm like yo get
it did what is nice man like it get
ready you guys I get some stuff you know
so that's it you guys got anything else
for the week burr for all this insanity
oh by the way sir
has random roles again about the air we
forgot about that yes rose literally 60
to 62 and 69 ollie no I'm not he what
might have had one of those like
currencies where you could buy some of
the old seasonal exotics like Marianas
Val and stuff I thought he might be
selling that I used to look around
ourselves on that well he sells the
weapons but where do you get the actual
D currency to buy those for oh the car
yeah that's right he supposed that bit
I'm thinking that's gonna be Thurman
there's one in the season pass raisin
pass season pass has one but I think you
draw them we're gonna get one you have
to choose between them season basically
yeah you season up for like you just
have to pick between any exotic because
in today's Onix are not a given so
they're letting you pick one well then
if you don't have Ariana's valve that's
the one you get this season that's the
one everybody seems to need no it
definitely is better than the rest
well man it's been 2 hours 45 about 3
hours man we got a we got a respect your
time man it's getting late I know you
were up early to start so it is man it
has been an absolute blast haven't you
bring bring all the positive vibes in
here tonight it's been man amazing to be
a part of it man thank y'all so much for
even letting me be on this podcast it's
an amazing deal man I I'm really
appreciative of being a man I really am
thank you brother appreciate you we had
to get it done
it's time for survival you know we sit
here in the last word campfire we all
whoa see we've been holding it down for
a longer situation talking about the
things that y'all tryin to step up on
and we talking about the DLCs and things
that's coming in the fall something
y'all to catch up on see we've been
trying to be the ones in the game man to
sit here talking preach you've been
watching last word for the longest
period of time all they'd like to do is
sit here and talk to you guys so they
can show y'all something to teach so
you've been going what we need to do man
as we see here and we live out and they
put the hype man a twitch in the
building for us to come here and vibe
out look I've been trying to beat a man
to be here and talk about the things
from starts but I respect both of these
individuals all together for the things
they talked about from the heart
understand man and we go from the finish
and I can't start I've been here doing
this thing for the longest period of
time
I can't drunk look I've been doing what
I need to do man until the rain stops so
I've been sitting here trying to grind
out these things and a lot of people
from endorsements want to invest in me
but I said no no ain't no invest of me
unless you plant destiny see we were
trying to be the best in this game
unless they tested me mmm but I've been
dropping my boss and my reasons being
keep on pushing this vain man ain't no
stopping me let's go I'm using the Dom
blade and shooting my focus shots on my
shots to be hitting off them headshots
make you very very mad we hate the toxic
people it's all about the positivity so
we've been doing everything and we're
loving it much more do what we need to
do dog and show the love and short fare
mmm big shout out to Cognito any bonta's
as they shown in love and as we can
video wherever you find this thing find
this man and send him some love because
man you can't find a better better
person that hang out with in twitch in
chat in game helping the entire new TB a
better community man this man in here is
making making destiny what it is one of
the one of the key cogs of what makes
this entire community ex one of the best
in gaming thank you so much see chances
going wow he killed he killed for sure
gotta do a battement salute to you
brother definitely appreciate the vows
we of course PG you know I'm saying
everything energy man everybody you're a
long day man once just relax kick the
feet up you know if I can find I like
your brother
but yeah better me for me you already
know the same thing I look at you know
on Twitter all that good stuff every
Sunday is the Lord's Day 1:00 p.m.
Eastern on our podcast YouTube we return
and we will have my man blaze 4k
whatever
representatives of the police station
nation he will be back in full force
we'll talk about everything that's going
on in the industry we'll talk about that
Playstation 5 reveal will talk about the
Miles Morales
you know expansion / sequel whatever it
is talk about that would talk about a
lot of topics Pam please tune it you
know the king is gonna be loaded he's
locked and loaded it's gonna be crazy
with a head yeah Billy's better come
with some ammo get his bag yeah Xbox all
day you know he's gonna say when he got
to say oh my god yeah salutare went to
the writers man Lords a game in dotnet
man really appreciate the guys are
working hard putting out good content
you guys are supporting it really feels
good to see you guys you know take to
the articles and stuff like that so on
yeah man of course it's me into the
statues king of statues is up check that
out
Kings got a crazy don't want statue
right now so you've been to the Marvel
to DC stuff and you want to get a little
synopsis when the characters check that
out and of course he hates what I say
this but the best damn salute man really
appreciate the lover to chat today again
salute oh my brother my bro
amaze coming through dropping knowledge
you know super fun I'm very glad he put
me on to your content and you have a fan
in me brother so keep doing what you're
doing thank you thank you yeah well
amazed let them know where they can find
you real quick and then we'll wrap this
thing up just right man it's switching
the building and you guys can find me
right here in a home of Bob's twitch.tv
slash amaze that's uhm two A's to Wes
Ziyi don't let it run passionate ladies
and gentlemen come by about what is over
here no my vibes positive vibes each and
every day ready to eat constantly each
and every person tell your family kids
and everybody come by and have a good
time it's it's like you've done that
before
I should be a video show for that man
give more for that bro like you are
literally like - it's like I said it's
the vibe I get when I'm in the car and
I'm zoning and I'll turn one of my
favorite whether it be a Sirius XM radio
station that it's like your channel this
is the Amaze serious energy right now
this is the vibe right now I am happy to
be doing this for him so it's a loop
every I'd be doing what you doing yes
absolutely
mine short and sweet I'll be streaming
I'll be playing you guys can find me
YouTube Twitter twitch a Bonta CBO and t
is look me up if you find the cheetah
likely that you found me so we gonna be
grinded we gonna be working all this
stuff lots of stuff to cover videos
guides to keep you guys informed this
has been amazing honestly thank you very
much it has been our pleasure to have
you here glad we made it work timing
wise I know we're cutting into that
grind on your vacation but we very proud
man to even be here man um on this
podcast the last word thank y'all man so
much for this is this is something very
very strongly and it's very touching so
I I I really truly appreciate it man
this is a moment I won't forget so I
appreciate it thank you guys for that
back at you man got it hold on wet my
eyes here getting
everybody in chat I want to send you
guys over to somebody so let's send a
little love out into the world of twitch
who we got we got any thoughts I got I
got to it's uh open I simply loved
actually I know let's send it back to
monkeys monkeys
okay you don't know manga start you're
definitely missing one of the best
artists in this community sex
we are gonna raid his channel here in
just a second once we wrap this thing up
but before we go we got to put the final
book in on this episode so thank you
guys chat you have been awesome amazed
you are amazing so thank you for coming
and joining us and for episode 107 June
12th it has been
the last word